souhaiter que nous conduisions également
cet exercice en réunion plénière nous
entendons tout d'abord les représentants
des syndicats je précise qu'une
invitation est envoyée aux organisations
syndicales représentatives au niveau
national et interprofessionnel la CFTC
m'a fait savoir qu'elle ne pourrait être
représenté et nous entendons ce matin
voilà monsieur beaugasse nous entendons
ce matin monsieur Alexis Jamet
conseiller confédéral non il n'est pas
là
conseiller confédéral Confédération
générale du travail CGT
Ivan Ricordeau ça c'est bon
secrétaire national responsable de la
politique sur la retraite de la
Confédération française démocratique du
travail
la CFDT
je vais donner la parole à chaque
intervenant afin qu'il expose brièvement
les principales observations de
l'organisation qu'il représente sur ce
texte avant qu'un débat ne s'engage avec
nos rapporteurs
rapporteur général René Paul Savary
rapporte
et Sylvie vermeyer rapporteur pour avis
de la commission des finances puis
ensuite avec nos collègues je vous
laisse la parole alors qui commence de
commencer peut-être on fait comme ça OK
donc ça tombe bien bonjour bonjour à
toutes et à tous merci pour pour cette
discussion c'est très important pour la
CFDT d'avoir un échange avec les
sénatrices les sénateurs à avant
l'ouverture des débats dans
au Sénat dans quelques jours c'est
d'autant plus important qu'il y a
beaucoup de commentaires qui
s'effectuent sur les enjeux du débat
parlementaire en cours et que il est
important pour notre organisation
d'avoir un débat sur le fond c'est ce
qui importe
pour les pour les travailleurs de ce
pays c'est clairement la nature des
discussions qui ont lieu y compris quand
les discussions se passent dans la rue
au moment où il y a des cortèges
nombreux dans dans la période c'est
vraiment des discussions sur ce qu'est
le monde du travail aujourd'hui que
représente la retraite et ça nous
important que dans l'ensemble des des
lieux où ce projet de réforme doit être
débattu qu'il se fasse de la façon la
plus approfondie et la plus apaisée
possible c'est ce qu'on essaye de
conduire en termes de responsabilité
donc c'est de cette façon là qu'on
souhaite échanger pendant deux heures
avec vous ce matin quelques mots de
d'introduction avant d'avoir le
traditionnel échange sur le fond à
partir de de vos de vos points
d'intention prioritaires la CFDT regarde
la situation en face sur la question des
retraites il nous semble qu'il y a trois
paramètres qui sont importants ou trois
enjeux qui sont importants quand on
discute des retraites c'est qu'est-ce
qui se passe dans le monde du travail
dans la période actuelle qui nécessite
qu'on regarde qu'on a juste les éléments
de transition entre la carrière
professionnelle et la période de
retraite et donc il y a des enjeux
particulièrement forts dans la période
actuelle post pandémique qui nécessite
que on a juste la façon se situe les
dernières parties d’activité pour
justement améliorer la question des
transitions il me semble que la question
des transitions professionnelles y
compris dans la dernière partie de
carrière et un élément qui qui bouge et
qui a beaucoup bougé y compris au moment
de la crise sanitaire le deuxième
élément qu'on regarde en face et que le
système de retraite porte en lui-même en
son sein de nombreuses inégalités et que
pour nous il est important pour y
répondre de avoir un élément de
refondation du système de retraite on a
beaucoup travaillé on s'est beaucoup
investi sur la façon dont il y avait des
améliorations trouvées dans le système
de retraite et que ces améliorations là
passeraient à terme c'est sans doute le
sens de l'histoire de l'évolution de la
production sociale de notre pays par un
système au moins de base universelle qui
permettent de donner les mêmes droits à
l'ensemble des travailleurs quel que
soit leur situation leur parcours
professionnel ou l'origine
professionnelle nous sommes que cet
élément fondateur qui a été débattu il y
a 3 ans dans notre pays sera
de construction et de renforcement de
notre système par répartition et le
troisième paramètre qu'on regarde en
face et la question de l'équilibre
financier qui est tout sauf un tabou
pour la CFDT parce que c'est le premier
élément de confiance dans un système par
répartition quand on veut avoir de la
confiance entre les générations il faut
faire la démonstration que le système
est à l'équilibre interne et donc on
sait toujours investi dans de nombreuses
réformes des retraites pour faire en
sorte de garantir cette pérennité
financière là et on regarde cette
question avec avec beaucoup de lucidité
dans la période actuelle donc si la
question est est-ce qu'il faut un
rendez-vous retraite alors
en janvier février mars 2023 ou courant
2023 peu importe la réponse pour la CFDT
est plutôt positive donc c'est le
premier élément de de positionnement de
notre organisation le deuxième élément
c'est que contrairement à des moments de
réforme sur le système de retraite qu'on
a connu dans notre pays depuis 20 ans on
n'est pas dans une situation dramatique
et c'est ce qui doit guider justement la
nature des échanges et la nature des
ajustements à faire pour nous on a et
donc on regarde avec beaucoup de
lucidité c'est ce que je dis c'est ce
que j'ai dit on a
un besoin d'équilibre financier aux
alentours d'une dizaine de milliards
d'euros dans dans la période à venir
c'est les chiffres alors on va pas on
discutera tout à l'heure sans doute des
des analyses des projections qui ont été
effectuées mais si on regarde cette cet
horizon là on peut convenir je pense de
façon assez raisonnable que le système
de retraite au niveau financier nous dit
deux choses c'est qu'il y a un
déséquilibre qu'il faut corriger car
rien à voir avec les déséquilibres qui
ont été corrigés aux réforme précédentes
et donc du coup quand on regarde ce qui
était les projections et les débats sur
la réforme 2014 2010 2003 il y a
absolument aucune
cohérence en termes de besoins
financiers par rapport à ce précédent
rendez-vous là ce d'autant plus que ces
rendez-vous là donnaient des
perspectives à long terme qui étaient
des perspectives on chute libre des
perspectives dégradées alors que
aujourd'hui s'il y a un débat sur
l'horizon court terme de l'équilibre
financier je pense qu'il y a très peu de
débats pour dire que il y a une
perspective à long terme en chute libre
personne n'a dit ça dans le débat
retraite et donc du coup il est hors de
question pour la CFDT de dramatiser cet
élément là d'autant plus que plus le
débat avancé depuis le début de la
concentration l'automne plus les experts
se sont prononcés pour dire trois choses
c'est que ce déséquilibre là il existe
il est pas dramatique que la question de
la projection sur le système de retraite
des éléments qui avaient été donnés sur
la fonction publique son sujet à caution
et que les démographes de plus en plus
disent que la question de l'espérance de
vie fait aussi partie des éléments
correctifs à terme sur ce qui avait été
travaillé jusqu'à maintenant donc du
coup ces éléments là la CFDT je vous ai
dit regardez le rendez-vous avec
lucidité regarde ce rendez-vous sans
aucune dramatisation et on on n'est
jamais tombé dans le débat débat de
dramatisation financière donc du coup
l'enjeu pour nous et comment répartit
l'effort puisqu'il y a des éléments qui
sont qui sont à travailler dans
l'évolution du système de retraite et il
est hors de question pour la sfdt de
faire répartir les efforts uniquement
sur les travailleurs
de tout temps quand on a fait évoluer le
système de retraite on l'a fait évoluer
avec une répartition entre ce que les
entreprises contribuent à l'évolution du
système de retraite est-ce que les
travailleurs contribuent sur sur
leur cotisations on a un projet de loi
qui fait répartir les efforts uniquement
sur les salariés donc on a un élément de
difficulté selon nous de cet arbre là et
le deuxième élément c'est que la seule
d'État a toujours été opposée au
décalage d'un paramètre sur les
différents paramètres qui existent qui
est le paramètre de l'âge parce que en
décalant ce paramètre là on fait
reporter l'effort uniquement sur une
partie des salariés et sur les salariés
qui sont les salariés les plus modestes
alors contrairement à d'autres réformes
qui ont vu des décalage de l'âge les
salariés les plus modestes ceux des
premiers des cils en termes de
rémunération sont eux épargnés de la
réforme parce que c'est des salariés qui
bénéficient la retraite à 67 ans et
comme il n'y a pas de décalage de la
décote du coup cet amortisseur là
continue à fonctionner donc il y a pas
de mieux mais il y a pas de pierre pour
les premiers des cils par contre pour
l'ensemble des cils au dessus du
troisième des cils jusqu'au 9 et 10e là
par contre la facture elle est lourde et
donc la CFDT est opposée au fait que ça
soit notamment les classes moyennes et
les travers de la deuxième ligne qui
payent l'ensemble de la facture de la
réforme des retraites ce qui est le
projet qui nous est présenté aujourd'hui
en faisant le choix de décaler l'âge de
62 à 64 ans donc en conclusion
cette affaire-là méritait que yait un
rendez-vous dans notre pays qui soit le
rendez-vous du comme on travaille mieux
et dans le donc qui nécessitait
d'aborder la question par la question du
travail ce que peut pas faire un pdfss
et encore moins un peu les fesses
rectificatif donc fallait aborder la
question par le travail aborder la
question par les questions d'emploi et
de plein emploi et d'emploi des seniors
et dans ce cadre là poser la question de
l'évolution du système de retraite y
compris de la durée d'activité c'était
ça le système vertueux qui permettait de
poser les bases d'un débat
approfondi sur l'évolution de notre
système de protection sociale on est
aujourd'hui dans un rendez-vous qui est
un rendez-vous d'ajustement financier
dans un cadre FSS et on le voit à
travers le débat et la nuit en est la
démonstration flagrante c'est que du
coup on a un débat qui réduit à comment
on envoie un ajustement financier et
comment dans cette ajustement financier
là on trouve quelques amortisseurs et la
mauvaise nouvelle de cette nuit c'est
que l'enjeu essentiel qui était de faire
en sorte que l'on prenne des seniors
soit quand même un peu la clé de voûte
de cette affaire-là à terme bah on voit
que l'ambition qui était déjà pas très
élevée permettez-moi de le dire comme ça
et retomber à son plus bas niveau et que
ça augure d'un continuation des débats
et qui va être particulièrement
difficile sur ce terrain là qui nous
semble pourtant le terrain prioritaire
voilà sur les propos liminaires de la
CFDT ne rentre pas dans les éléments
précis qu'on a débattu dans le cadre de
la concertation je pense qu'on y
reviendra dans le cadre des échanges
juste après merci de votre attention
bonjour à vous et au nom de la CGT à mon
tour on vous remercie de ce moment
d'échange et d'écoute du coup des
organisations syndicales puisque vous
avez devant vous les représentants de de
l'ensemble de fêtes des organisations
syndicales qui toutes vous explique leur
opposition à ce projet de loi antisocial
pour les travailleuses et travailleurs
nous rappelons que le principal argument
du gouvernement après avoir tenté quand
même de faire croire qu'il était de
justice sociale et finalement devenu
l'équilibre financier que là aussi pour
nous comme le vient de le dire mon
collègue repose sur de faux constats
tout d'abord bon pour nous il n'y a pas
de problème pour financer le système de
retraite par répartition parce que comme
les organisations syndicales vous
l'expliquent même monsieur Brun
le président du corps a déclaré que les
dépenses de retraite ne dérapent pas ce
qui pose problème
au gouvernement je le cite c'est ce que
dit le président du corps c'est que ce
sont les dépenses qui ne sont pas
compatibles avec les objectifs de
politique économique et de finances
publiques du gouvernement il est donc
clair pour la CGT comme pour tous les
syndicats et j'insiste l'écrasante
majorité de la population aujourd'hui
que l'objectif de cette réforme des
retraites et de faire payer aux
travailleurs les aides publiques et
autres allégement successifs de
cotisations sociales que la majorité
présidentielle défend en fait cette
réforme comme ça vient d'être dit aussi
elle veut imposer des nombrescules
sociaux pour des résultats budgétaires
extrêmement faibles et non nécessaire
nous insistons aussi sur ces deux sujets
aujourd'hui les arrangements si je puis
dire avec la réalité du gouvernement
relève quasi de l'irrespect vis-à-vis
des salariés cela fait plusieurs
semaines que la CGT les autres
organisations syndicales alertes par
exemple sur la proposition présentée
comme une mesure de
[Musique]
64 ans reculé encore l'âge de départ à
la retraite c'est rendre toujours plus
difficile la validation d'une carrière
complète et qui dit carrière incomplète
dit pension incomplète pour ceux qui
malgré tout parviendront à bénéficier
d'une carrière complète même l'étude
d'impact réalisé par le gouvernement
évalue entre 0,3 et 1,5 % les
augmentations de pension conséquence de
l'allongement de la durée de travail à
qui veut-on faire croire que c'est un
progrès le rapport
de le report pardon de l'âge légal de 62
à 64 ans est inacceptable allongez l'âge
de départ ce n'est pas connaître la
réalité du travail et c'est l'un élément
fondamental cela va impacter l'ensemble
des salariés du public comme du privé à
un âge où la pénibilité liée au travail
et partagée par tous et toutes que l'on
soit infirmière ou alerte par exemple
sur le taux d'accident du travail
supérieur à celui du BTP c'est dire ou
même au cadre où la pression travail et
le développement massif des risques
psychosociaux qui l'induit l'exemple le
plus frappant ce sont les troubles
musculo-squelettiques première maladie
professionnelle en France plus de 440
cas en 2019 touchant autant les
personnels soignants les métiers la
logistique les employés sur les chaînes
de production et autres préparateurs de
commande cela va impacter en priorité
les salaires
avec des carrières les salariés avec des
carrières les plus hachées et les
salariés les plus modestes à chaque fois
que l'on modifie l'âge de départ en
retraite on pénalise d'ailleurs
notamment profondément les femmes à
chaque fois que l'on repousse la durée
de cotisation requise on la rend
toujours moins atteignable notamment
pour les femmes notamment par l'absence
de politique ambitieuse d'égalité
homme-femme et liés autant de autant
partielle subis en 2020 26% des femmes
salariées à temps partiel le son pour
s'occuper de leurs enfants ou d'une
personne dépendante allongez encore la
durée de cotisation creuserait donc
encore le fossé des inégalités entre les
femmes et les hommes quant aux carrière
longue alors qu'aujourd'hui les
travailleurs et travailleuses peuvent
partir à 60 ans il et elle travailleront
de longues années de plus avec cette
réforme pire il et elle devront cotiser
jusqu'à 43 ou 44 ans puisque il y a une
nouvelle annonce vous avez vu hier de
Madame la première
mais on ne sait pas si c'est à nouveau
une annonce ou d'un énième effet de
communication pour faire diversion enfin
reporter l'âge de départ à retraite ces
reportés le paiement des pensions de
retraite sur les autres prestations
sociales partir plus vieux c'est partir
en plus mauvaise santé avec recours plus
souvent au arrêt maladie plus exposées
aux invalidités et c'est aussi je vous
alerte si je puis me permettre sur le
sujet
moindre retraité en bonne santé pour les
activités bénévoles pour la solidarité
pour ce qui fait liant dans la société
pour celles et ceux qui s'occupent des
projets dents etc vous le connaissez
cela nous insistons aussi sur ce sujet
c'est la même chose avec les
travailleuses et les travailleurs dites
seniors à 60 ans vous le savez aussi un
actif aujourd'hui sur de seulement et
ton corps en activité parfois seulement
à temps partiel l'augmentation du nombre
d'annuités à valider en lien avec le
report de l'âge de départ à la retraite
entraînera donc un allongement de le sas
de précarité et une baisse massive du
nombre de travailleurs et travailleuses
en capacité d'atteindre une carrière
complète la prise en compte de la dite
pénibilité et de notre point de vue
scandaleuse et bien évidemment pas à la
hauteur perte de 2 ans pour les
personnes ayant commencé entre 18 et 20
ans et éligible dispositif carrière
longue le gouvernement nous parle de
pénibilité après avoir retiré quatre
critères lors du passage du c-3p au C2P
en 2017 et sont les mêmes qui toujours
en 2017 ont supprimé les chcct comité
d'hygiène et de sécurité des conditions
de travail avec les ordonnances dites
Macron l'attaque contre les régimes
spéciaux qui sont les régimes qui
prennent le plus en compte la pénibilité
la pénibilité au travail les régimes
pionniers dit spéciaux va d'ailleurs à
rebours complet de la reconnaissance de
la pénibilité dans ces secteurs
nous accélération nous
assistons à une accélération de la
réforme Touraine couplée à la réforme
proposée par le gouvernement borne qui
va entraîner un raccourcissement de la
durée espérée passer à la retraite c'est
la seule réforme qui joue à la fois sur
la légale de départ et sur le nombre
d'années cotisées les seules variables
que souhaitent finalement le patronat
jamais ne sont discutés l'augmentation
des salaires des cotisations sociales
l'égalité homme-femme la taxation des
produits des grands groupes des profits
des grands groupes c'est pourtant ce que
demande aujourd'hui les salariés qui
produisent les richesses de ce pays
pour finir
l'urgence de la population c'est
d'augmenter les salaires et pas de
reculer l'âge de départ à la retraite la
population vous le dit par million à
travers des sondages des pétitions des
grèves des manifestations y compris avec
la participation de certains petits
patrons qui comprennent bien qu'on ne
peut pas faire travailler les salariés
jusqu'à 64 ans l'heure est au retrait du
projet il y a tellement d'autres sujets
importants à traiter nous insistons les
citoyens regarderont attentivement le
vote de chaque parlementaire répondez
positivement à leurs attentes
répondez positivement à leurs attentes
on est là pour échanger et alerter
s'il vous plaît on se calme on se calme
on débat on se calme on n'est pas on
n'est pas dans l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée nationale s'il vous plaît
donc on se calme
on se calme on se calme on se calme et
maintenant la parole est à qui monsieur
Boga
oui merci
voilà
il y a eu le petit effet je peux
je vais attendre oui oui mais écoutez on
est là pour débattre effectivement et
donc si vous nous avez si vous nous avez
invité le côté déplacé de la remarque
mais néanmoins nous continuons le débat
non je veux dire
moi je trouve que jeté à la vindique
populaire les parlementaires quel que
soit le choix de leur vote ne fait pas
partie du débat démocratique point donc
chacun le verra chacun pourra le voir
mais ce n'est pas c'est une forme de
menace je persiste et signe mais
néanmoins nous continuons le débat je
vous remercie voilà mais tout le monde
sait tout ce que tout le monde vote donc
il y a pas besoin voilà donc c'est bon
voilà Michel bogas
de me couper mon électricité ou de
menacer ma famille ou m'envoyer des
mails et des lettres de menaces au
parlementaire c'est inadmissible voilà
ce n'est pas le sujet mais il y en a qui
qui poursuivent dans cette voie donc je
tiens voilà donc monsieur Google vous
avez la parole
voilà merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs merci d'avoir
organisé cette cette rencontre ou
effectivement les organisations
syndicales et
vous allez l'entendre partage un certain
nombre de constats sur le projet de loi
qui est qui est proposé le premier des
constats c'est que effectivement il y a
pas d'urgence à réformer le système de
retraite tel qu'il est et il y a surtout
pas d'urgence à ne faire que un seul
paramètre c'est-à-dire reculer l'âge de
départ à la retraite pour l'ensemble des
salariés de ce pays c'est à dire de
passer de 62 ans à 64 ans tout en
parallèle en accélérant ce qu'on a
l'habitude de dire la réforme Touraine
qui en fait touchera les gens
dès 1900
la génération
1966 au lieu de la génération 19
73 notre opposition à ce projet est basé
en fait sur les constats que soit il n'y
a pas d'urgence mais que la première des
préoccupations et ça a été dit par une
des organisations c'est d'abord l'emploi
nous avons fait des propositions
gouvernement en matière d'emploi
notamment en matière d'emploi des
seniors et il nous semble aujourd'hui
que le gouvernement prend les choses à
l'envers on aurait dû d'abord traiter
les problématiques d'emploi des seniors
des études économiques démontrent que
d'augmenter de 10 points le taux
d'emploi des seniors rapporte 50
milliards et quand on oppose les 50
milliards ou 10 milliards projetés je
rappelle bien projeté parce que ce ne
sont que des projections du corps et
donc ce n'est pas la réalité il y a cinq
ans le corps prévoyait 2021-2022
déficitaire alors que il est
excellentaire sur l'ensemble des régimes
de retraite d'accord quand on prend
l'ensemble donc ce ne sont que des
projections et il n'y a pas il n'y a pas
à s'alar
tel que le fait le gouvernement
travaillons d'abord sur une loi qui
protège les salariés de ce pays pour que
les entreprises arrêtent de licencier à
partir de 50 ans les seniors et les
laisser et les laisser comme ça au
chômage et au chômage pour de nombreuses
années puisqu'on sait que quand un
travailleur senior et au chômage il
reste le plus longtemps c'est lui qui
reste le plus longtemps et on trouve les
seniors dans les demandeurs d'emploi de
longue durée
l'autre cas c'est effectivement il y a
une étude du CNAM qui vient de sortir au
mois de février qui fait la
démonstration que lors du passage de 60
à 62 ans on a vu chez les seniors une
augmentation des arrêts maladie ça veut
dire que faire travailler les gens plus
longtemps c'est un transfert vers
d'autres caisses sociales c'est un
transfert vers les maladies vers la
sécurité sociale c'est un transfert vert
la caisse de chômage c'est un transfert
vers et vous qui représentez les
territoires vers en fait les minima
sociaux voilà c'est simplement juste un
transfert et c'est un transfert pour
plus d'un tiers des économies prévues il
faut bien l'avoir en tête et que donc
pour nous il suffit d'abord de
travailler sur les questions d'emploi de
faire en sorte que les entreprises et
c'est pas avec un index que les gens que
les entreprises conserveront les seniors
c'est avec des contraintes je rappelle
que l'index égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes sur les salaire on constate
encore aujourd'hui en moyenne 20% des
cas de salaire et c'est 20% là
si les salaires des femmes étaient
égales au salaire des hommes il n'y
aurait pas de problématiques il n'y
aurait pas de problématiques de recettes
dans les caisses de retraite voilà c'est
ça qu'il faut faire c'est d'abord ça et
c'est bien ça qu'il faut mettre qu'il
faut mettre en avant aujourd'hui on
laisse monsieur Bocasse s'exprimer même
si on apprend ses propos
oui c'est un peu mais écoutez voilà et
donc
les problématiques là sont les
principales problématiques et donc c'est
bien des questions d'emploi de
conditions de travail et de salaire qui
font qu'aujourd'hui et bien il y a moins
de recettes parce que c'est c'est pas un
problème de dépenses les retraites c'est
écrit dans les tous les rapports du
corps c'est un problème de recettes
d'abord c'est d'abord un problème de
recettes etc c'est un manque de
cotisations
et ces cotisations bien évidemment et
bien il faudra regarder d'un autre côté
toutes les exonérations qui ont été
faites aux entreprises
Force Ouvrière porte le fait que toutes
les exonérations toutes les aides aux
entreprises doivent être conditionnées
conditionnés à l'égalité salariale entre
les hommes et les femmes et les femmes
et les hommes conditionnés au maintien
des salariés en emploi qu'ils soient
jeunes ou seniors d'ailleurs et une fois
qu'on aura conditionné les aides qu'on
ne dit pas il y a des entreprises qui
ont besoin des aides mais je suis pas
sûr que les entreprises du CAC 40 on est
vraiment besoin quand on voit les
profits qu'ils ont qu'ils ont
aujourd'hui qu'ils ont aujourd'hui
engrangés donc nous aurons
nous avons alors je pense qu'il y aura
un débat mais nous avons donné le
gouvernement des dettes enfin des
documents iti sur l'emploi des seniors
sur comment préserver l'emploi des
seniors sur l'égalité salariale
également
par exemple nous avons fait une
proposition
et bien que les aides soient aussi
conditionnées dans le cas du temps
partiel subi pour les femmes 89% du
temps partiel en France est subit et il
est subi par les femmes je suis je suis
syndicalisé je viens de la grande
distribution et bien croyez moi une
hôtesse de caisse à la pas le choix on
lui demande pas de travailler à temps
plein on lui impose un contrat de
travail à temps partiel et c'est ça
qu'il faut et c'est là où il y a une
difficulté ensuite à la retraite entre
les femmes et les hommes la différence
elle est là et c'est tout ça qu'il faut
changer avant de penser à reculer l'âge
de départ voilà je me tiens à votre
disposition ensuite pour débattre avec
vous de ce que nous pouvons proposer
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
bonjour à toutes et à tous alors je vais
adapter un peu mon propos à ce qui a
déjà été dit par mes collègues afin de
pas être trop long mais je précise parce
que tout le monde se lève pour voir la
pancarte
secrétaire général et d'ailleurs je
voudrais ce titre vu qu'on avait été
reçu par Monsieur Savary madame douano
et une autre collègue qui est ici il y a
quelques semaines j'avais communiqué des
éléments écrits au secrétariat de la
commission je sais pas si ça a circulé
mais je vais m'appuyer là dessus pour
mon propos avant je voudrais juste
souligner que on a été très déçu de la
concertation avec le gouvernement où il
y a eu très peu d'écoute à l'automne ou
finalement on sentait qu'on était déjà
sur une réforme dogmatique et je me
disais ben dans le projet de loi qui va
être soumis et en particulier les
éléments assimilables à une étude
d'impact on va trouver des choses et la
grosse déception vu que sur un certain
nombre de choses alors je prendrai en
particulier l'article 2 sur l'emploi des
seniors alors qu'on est dans un projet
de loi
rectificatif certes mais de financement
de la sécurité sociale il y a un certain
nombre de cases qui sont prévus à
renseigner au niveau de la CNAM au
niveau des autres caisses d'assurance
maladie et moi si je prends sur l'emploi
des seniors donc il se limite à un
emploi seniors un index au seniors et
ben rien n'est mis sur les conséquences
que ça pourrait avoir sur les arrêts
maladie qui se multiplient comme la
souligner Michel Boga etc et donc cette
étude d'impact est vraiment enfin
j'imagine que vous représentant de la
nation et parlementaire vous l'avez
décelé comme ça mais c'est une
enfin je veux dire c'est inadmissible
d'avoir aussi peu d'éléments
justificatifs à une réforme comme ça bon
je vais vous dire que de mon côté j'ai
pris quelques contacts avec des juristes
constitutionnels qui
bon soufflet qui avait des démarches à
entreprendre sur ce sujet donc
voilà on voit aucune
impact sur l'assurance chômage sur
l'assurance maladie sur la caisse à
accident du travail maladie
professionnelle qui va être très
concerné et si on prend l'article 7
alors on voit le comme seul impact qui
est listé c'est les amandes qui seraient
éventuellement enfin les pénalités qui
seraient éventuellement infligées si
l'indique l'index au senior n'était pas
publié par un pourcentage donné
d'entreprise donc si vous voulez
ça fait un peu léger quand même un comme
conséquence etc sur l'article 7 pareil
il y a des éléments incohérents vu que
on voit bien qu'il est justifié
l'augmentation de l'âge à partir de
statistiques d'augmentation d'espérance
de vie de 99 à 2019 alors qu'on sait
bien que
Céline c'est qui le montrent l'espérance
de vie n'augmente malheureusement plus
depuis
2014 donc ça fait 8 ans et que
l'évolution de 99 à
2012-2013 bah elle a été prise en compte
dans la loi Touraine et elle s'est
traduit déjà par une augmentation de la
durée de cotisation donc si vous voulez
il y a des arguments qu'on peut
qualifier de bidon qu'on qualifie comme
ça dans la presse et qui est aussi
interpelle un certain nombre de juristes
et qui fait que c'est je pense la
représentation nationale devrait
s'émouvoir de d'aussi peu enfin de
justification ou de leur
degré de validité
bon un certain nombre de gens qui ont
pignon sur rue moi je parlerai d'un pas
de Monsieur bras mais de Hervé le bras
qui a un expert démographe de l'Institut
national démographique qui a lui-même
mentionné qui effectivement les
hypothèses d'espérance de vie qui est
d'évolution d'espérance de vie n'était
pas réaliste et donc à un moment donné
on espère tous qu'il y a un moment donné
il y aura des facteurs qui feront
qu'elle repartira à la hausse mais
attendons de constater qu'elle repartent
à la hausse pour
justifier encore des projections à la
hausse pour justifier l'âge de départ
l'augmentation de l'âge de départ alors
après nous ce qu'on a fait parce que
devant ce manque
d'éléments du gouvernement et bien on a
fait nos propres chiffrages parce qu'il
y avait dans le rapport du corps des
coefficients de sensibilité etc et comme
les projections d'équilibre financier
sont l'argument majeurs qui est pris par
le gouvernement pour justifier ce report
de l'âge et ben on a fait nos propres
chiffrages et finalement quand on
considère un scénario espérance de vie
constante là où la première ministre
disait alors je reprends une référence
un article du Parisien du 2 décembre et
disait il y a 100 milliards d'euros de
déficit dans les 10 ans qui viennent et
bien
un chiffrage espérance de vie constante
montre que ces 47 milliards d'euros de
sur les 10 ans qui viennent de
alors essentiellement de dépens en moins
là mais de que de positivité sur
lesquelles financiers de notre régime de
retraite on a également considéré
l'emploi des seniors parce que
finalement quand vous regardez dans le
poids des seniors aucune conséquence
financière n'avait été né chiffrée dans
le l'impact du projet de loi ce qui
corrobore l'idée que l'index senior
était une mesure bidon finalement vu que
le gouvernement n'a même pas chiffré
d'impact sur l'emploi des seniors nous
on a fait nos évaluations et si on
améliorait comme l'ont d'ailleurs
chiffré aussi des gens Hervé Lorenzi par
exemple et certains de ses collègues et
bien on arrive à montrer que c'est plus
de 40 milliards d'euros aussi sur les 10
ans qui viennent donc vous voyez en gros
si on avait un emploi des seniors
amélioré mais amélioré dans la tranche
d'âge 57 à 62 63 ans pas on allait en
faire travailler les gens à 64 65 66 ou
77 ans pour ceux que l'augmentation de
l'âge de départ forcera à faire et bien
on aurait déjà un système qui par
rapport au scénario central du corps qui
est pris en référence serait à
l'équilibre sur les 10 ans qui viennent
alors qu'on est encore dans une période
où il y a un effet du pepy-boom on sait
que le Pepe boom joue mais pour ça les
régimes qui sont bien gérés qui sont
ceux des salariés de privés et un grand
nombre de régimes spéciaux mais ils ont
180 milliards d'euros de réserve pour
faire face à cette bosse et sa personne
n'en parle dans les études d'impact or
ces réserves qui ont été constituées
l'ont été en grande partie pour faire
face à la projection démographique liée
au Peppy boom et donc ça faut quand même
la voir en tête quand on parle
d'équilibre d'équilibre financier
ensuite et bien on en vient au partage
de la valeur parce que on voit que le
partage de la valeur mes collègues dans
évoquer on a vu encore les chiffres
récents des dividendes et des rafales
d'actions effectués en 2022 par les
groupes du CAC 40 80 milliards d'euros
et bien sûr on revenait un partage de la
valeur plus équilibrée et on n'a pas
fait des des calculs irréalistes on a
dit il faut revenir alors que la part
des salariés à diminuer de 5% du du pub
dans les 25 ans passés nous on a dit on
revient on rééquilibre on gagne 2% dans
les 10 ans qui viennent progressivement
du fait d'une loi qui pourrait être
votée d'ici fin 2023 et qui rentrerait
en effet en 2025 par exemple et qui
serait associé une meilleure gouvernance
des entreprises qui irait de pair avec
une
plus d'investissements donc plus de
création d'emplois
ce qui serait homogène d'ailleurs et
cohérent avec les discours du
gouvernementaux de réindustrialisation
de souveraineté économiques etc et donc
qui permettrait sans problème de ramener
plus de 100 milliards d'euros dans à nos
régimes de retraite dans les 10 ans qui
viennent et qui montrent que notre
système de retraite avec tous ces
éléments et bien il permet clairement de
financer les mesures de solidarité qui
ont évoqué mes collègues et sur lesquels
je ne reviendrai pas les petites
retraites etc donc on voit bien qu'il y
a un gros problème sociétal un système
de retraite on voit bien le poids
financier qu'il a et les impacts qu'il a
sur la vie des gens c'est un sujet
sociétal et le traité en quelques
semaines de débat parlementaires
sur dans le cas d'un projet de loi de
finance et bien c'est vraiment très
réducteur donc nous voilà notre position
il n'y a pas de problème financier et
encore une fois les justificatifs amenés
par le gouvernement sont vraiment
fallacieux pour vis-à-vis des
parlementaires et vis-à-vis de l'opinion
qui elle-même a bien compris parce que
nous aussi on fait de la pédagogie là où
le gouvernement fait de la communication
et des tient des éléments de langage et
ben nos concitoyens ont bien compris les
éléments et qu'on les emmenait dans une
impasse et on fait confiance à la
représentation nationale pour ne pas
voter ce projet de loi après je pourrais
revenir en détail sur un certain nombre
d'autres éléments
et bien merci à vous quatre tout de
suite la parole à Elisabeth Doisneau
rapporteur général
merci madame la Présidente je voudrais
commencer par vous remercier on a eu
l'occasion effectivement déjà de vous
rencontrer alors peut-être pas tous mais
en tout cas je crois que voilà on a bien
des occasions et je pense qu'il faut en
dehors d'un projet comme celui-ci d'un
projet de réforme il faut se voir
régulièrement moi je regrette tout
simplement que finalement parce que
votre engagement il est important parce
que
il permet à l'ensemble des personnes que
vous représentez de mieux comprendre les
réformes mais comme les avancées
sociales ou comme peut-être ce que vous
pouvez qualifier de retour en arrière
mais en tout cas vous vous avez cette
vocation de de pédagogie et puis de
réflexion et moi je voudrais vous
remercier parce que je trouve qu'en
France les syndicats sont pas
suffisamment représentés alors là en ce
moment on voit qu'il y a un regain
d'adhésion dans vos dans vos syndicats
mais je pense qu'il faut tenir l'affaire
il faut tenir la faire parce que si vous
voulez avancer sur
comment l'égalité entre mes femmes en
termes de salaire si vous voulez avancer
sur le travail des seniors si vous
voulez avancer sur le temps partiel tous
ces sujets mais que nous aussi
nous essayons de comprendre parce que ce
sont des phénomènes certainement qui
sont encouragés par notre système et
donc il faut réfléchir à le corriger
mais on ne peut pas non plus le faire
sans vous et moi je le dis j'ai j'ai
vraiment ce respect pour votre travail
mais surtout j'ai du respect dans le
sens où il faut effectivement que vous
soyez plus fort au sein des entreprises
plus fortes pas seulement au moment où
justement il y a une réforme des
retraites et moi je suis pour ce comment
cet échange mais régulier et en dehors
de de ces moments de crispation parce
qu'on en arriverait pas aux mots qui ont
été tenus tout à l'heure moi j'ai pas
été élu pour qu'on me dise quoi faire en
fait j'ai un parcours vous avez le vôtre
nous avons donc des angles
d'appréciation différents mais quand je
vous écoute quand je vous reçois dans ma
permanence dans mon département et bien
je me mets à l'écoute comme vous vous le
faites vis-à-vis des salariés que vous
rencontrez et je crois que c'est
important que vous compreniez que en
tout cas moi je me sens pas dans une
seringue et que je ne veux pas l'être ni
par les uns ni par les autres
je pense qu'il faut simplement du
respect nos enfants nous regardent nos
petits-enfants nous regarderons je pense
qu'on laisse une mémoire collective une
mémoire collective et bien en fait à
l'Assemblée comme ici mais comme dans la
rue et bien il faut que ça s'entretienne
donc le respect le respect parce qu'il
encourage la confiance voilà pour ces
quelques mots et c'est pas une leçon que
je donne c'est ma propre leçon de vie
que je partage
après ça je voudrais vous dire que on a
eu l'occasion de nous autres rapporteurs
de vous poser des questions donc c'est
vrai que j'ai plutôt envie de laisser la
main à tous ceux qui n'étaient pas là
lors des auditions vous dire simplement
qu'on est quand même d'accord sur le
constat le constat c'est de dire que le
système est durablement en déficit
pourquoi comme vous l'avez dit c'est pas
les dépenses et d'ailleurs voilà les
expressions du corps ont permis de bien
comprendre entre ce qu'ils ont dit à un
moment ce qu'ils ont rectifié un autre
moment en termes de compréhension parce
que c'est vrai que vous l'avez dit les
éléments de langage ils sont d'un côté
comme de l'autre je dirais que chacun
profite un petit peu des slogans qui
peut afficher donc ce qu'il faut qu'on
essaie de faire nous c'est comment
dirais-je
de dire les choses factuellement telles
qu'elles sont après chacun voilà avec sa
curiosité personnelle parce que je pense
qu'il faut que chaque citoyen aussi ce
document personnellement il est
important que
on ne se fige pas sur un seul son de
cloche donc pour vous dire que oui il
est durement en difficulté parce que
c'est effectivement les recettes qui
vont manquer puisque moi d'actifs pour
des retraités c'est vraiment l'équation
qui va se poser à nous et donc comment
comment on peut
faire en sorte de de répondre à cette
difficulté parce que tous les autres
pays je dirais à peu près européen mais
de notre catégorie ont quand même avancé
l'âge de départ à la retraite après avec
des systèmes qui sont un peu différents
moi j'entendais monsieur Ricordeau
parler d'un système
je sais pas comment vous le qualifiez à
point ou un peu de capitalisation je
sais pas j'aurais voulu avoir plus à
point j'aurais voulu avoir plus
d'éléments par rapport oui mais en même
temps en même temps il faut être très
très précis là-dessus parce que à point
sont capables d'avoir des points en
quelle CIR et avec quel niveau de
salaire ça c'est aussi pour moi quelque
chose qui peut être un peu inversant une
égalitaire enfin il s'agit pas de faire
l'égalité mais il s'agit d'être juste or
aujourd'hui les Français souvent ah bah
ils se compare au voisin tiens il a pas
travaillé il a pas cotisé pour que leur
une retraite c'est souvent voilà c'est
simpliste mais c'est ce qu'on entend
donc c'est ce qu'on nous on essaye
d'expliquer bon donc voilà moi j'ai
seulement ce petit cette petite question
à vous poser par rapport à vos propos
j'aimerais que vous les que vous comment
expliquer monsieur ricordo ce que vous
envisagez dans ce cette retraite à point
peut-être que vos autres collègues sont
pas tout à fait d'accord avec vous
d'ailleurs
oui on a déjà eu l'occasion d'échanger
donc j'ai pas de question plus
particulières c'est vrai que chacun fait
des propositions qui sont différentes
l'aide conditionné des entreprises de
Fogg j'ai travaillé dessus vous
proposiez également les primes pour
l'emploi des seniors s'intéressant la
CFDT je suis en train d'analyser les
propositions que vous faites vous avez
des avis dévergence et tout à fait
normal et tous les systèmes de toute
façon on va pas pouvoir compenser les
inégalités qu'il y a au niveau du
travail or là notre épure c'est la
retraite quelque chose de très notre
feuille de route c'est vachement limité
moi c'est une réforme
paramétrique donc elle peut pas tout
gommer
vous vous dites le système par point et
la CGT dit carrière hachée pension
hachée carrière incomplète pension
incomplète mais par point c'est encore
pire par point c'est encore pire
c'est encore pire que le système
paranuité donc vous voyez bien que de
toute façon quelque soit les systèmes
contenus de la complexité des inégalités
du travail
le système de retraite on va essayer de
gommer un petit peu ces inégalités mais
il y a les inégalités entre régime qui
apparaissent quand on parle que de
retraite 8 trimestres pour le privé deux
trimestres pour la fonction publique en
ce qui concerne les maternités donc on
voit bien que là aussi ces inégalités
c'est pas comme ça en claquant les lois
qu'on va bon
quel que soit ce qu'on lit on voit bien
que on a un temps passé à la retraite
qui est plutôt fait identique à celui
qu'on connaissait il y a des dizaines
d'années avec une natalité qui diminue
donc mathématiquement il est bien on
voit bien que me semble-t-il le constat
qu'on peut faire c'est que le système ne
s'équilibre pas voilà après en ce qui
concerne effectivement les façons d'y
répondre elles sont forcément
différentes si on revient à notre épure
bon on va pas d'histoire d'âge entre
nous
simplement il faut bien constater quand
même et je pense que là vous le remettez
pas en cause les 43 ans de durée de
carrière
c'est pas ce qui est proposé par ce
gouvernement c'était proposé par le
gouvernement d'avant donc c'est 43 ans
d'activités il faut bien les prendre en
compte après il y a le facteur là
effectivement qui mais c'est 43 ans
d'activité pour bien prendre en compte
donc je vais essayer de rester dans la
réflexion simplement sur cet état de
fait que la loi actuelle même si ça
accélère on se projette dans l'avenir
c'est quand même 43 ans d'activité donc
après ça nous interpelle par rapport à
la longueur des carrières c'est un grand
sujet d'actualité
carrière longue
carrière longue ça veut dire par rapport
à la carrière normale qui sera de 43 ans
au-dessus de 43 ans quoi
non
mais bien d'accord 43 ans c'est une
caravane normale c'est pour ça que il
faut trouver des dispositifs alors votre
avis par rapport à ça et une fois qu'on
a des 43 ans il y a effectivement une
usure professionnelle ce qui est que
personne ne peut effectivement contester
c'est tout à fait normal donc nous on
essaye modestement par rapport à ce qui
nous est proposé de voir comment on peut
adoucir ces mesures de façon à prendre
en compte vos préoccupations qui sont
les notes aussi en ce qui concerne
l'usure professionnelle c'est la raison
pour laquelle on envisage de de rester
par exemple pour un certain nombre de
dispositifs à droit constant quand vous
avez des dispositifs actuellement qui
qui sont par exemple incapacité
permanente qui est on pourrait laisser à
l'âge actuel ces deux ans avant l'âge de
départ on pourrait rester aux droits
actuel par exemple est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est une façon quand même de
prendre en compte l'usure
professionnelle il y aurait pas
d'amélioration mais les repas
d'aggravation c'est déjà peut-être une
avancée
en ce qui concerne la retraite
progressive c'est pareil c'est
semble-t-il un moyen intéressant pour
faire une phase intermédiaire
quand on voit la durée moyenne de vie
maintenant au-delà de 85 ans vous avez
une je parle en masse une vingtaine
d'années pour l'éducation la formation
vous avez 22 à 25 ans de retraite et de
retraite pas pour une génération pour
deux générations bien souvent quand on
rencontre les personnes très âgées et
qu'on leur parle de retraite elle dit
mais mes enfants sont déjà en retraite
d'accord un enfant deux personnes en
retraite et puis il y a l'actif voilà
commençons en train de s'organiser
progressivement avec le vieillissement
de la population et ça c'est un constat
qui est incontournable donc il y a plus
qu'un actif donc et il va falloir qu'il
travaille effectivement un petit peu
plus longtemps cette activité alors la
retraite progressive peut être
intéressante parce que je pense
maintenant que dans un parcours
de
vie je parle en moyenne il y aura la
partie éducation la partie de vie active
et une partie intermédiaire une partie
intermédiaire qui sera incontournable de
quelques années qui sera cette
transition c'est pour ça qu'il faut
trouver
des accompagnement de l'emploi de ces
personnes expérimentées ou seniors de
façon à apprendre et vous avez des
propositions qui me semblent
intéressantes souvent qui ont peut-être
on peut reprendre là cette partie
intermédiaire faut qu'on travaille
là-dessus parce que ça ça peut nous
rassembler sinon le reste ça va nous
diviser mais il faut y travailler sur
cette partie alors est-ce que la
retraite progressive laissée à 60 ans
comme aujourd'hui est une solution moi
ça me paraît une solution plutôt que de
la décaler à 62 envoyer quel est votre
avis là-dessus et puis chacun une
proposition
par rapport à cette
cette vie de seniors intermédiaire
dont on pourrait s'en parler
une seule parce qu'on va pas diffuser
mais une seule proposition vous voyez
pour construire quelque chose
Sylvie vermeyer on en aura fini avec les
rapporteurs on vous laissera répondre et
ensuite on passera aux questions des
collègues Sylvie Vermeillet pour la
commission des finances merci madame la
Présidente et merci messieurs pour votre
présentation votre exposé juste quelques
questions
concernant tout d'abord
alors
tantôt il y a pas de déséquilibre
parfois il y en a un mais il est pas
dramatique
pas très grave en tout cas à corriger
monsieur ricordo vous parlez
éventuellement d'un besoin 10 milliards
vous avez vous avez pas été plus précis
sur les moyens de le corriger est-ce que
c'est simplement l'emploi senior est-ce
que vous pourriez revenir sur votre
votre manière de remédier à
ce déséquilibre et puis de façon par
contre un peu Générale vous êtes un peu
tous revenus sur
l'espérance de vie alors parfois vous
vous appuyez sur les travaux du corps et
parfois c'est le contraire vous
contestez ce que le corps a pu dire sur
la progression de l'espérance de vie
donc est-ce que vous pourriez repréciser
ce que vous pensez être juste dans la
projection de l'espérance de vie et puis
juste une question pour Monsieur le
représentant de la CGT
concernant la disparition de certains
régimes spéciaux
si je prends l'exemple de la RATP
avec une pension moyenne de 2800 euros
actuel
comment est-ce que vous expliquez que
pour ceux qui peuvent partir à 52 ans
5000 sur les il y a 5000 aujourd'hui
contractuels qui en étant parti à 52 ans
recontactualise avec la RATP pour faire
le même travail est-ce que vous
considérez qu'on est dans une situation
de pénibilité dans ce cas là
alors voilà qui qui commence à répondre
on prend le même ordre monsieur rigordon
c'est Monsieur Vacheron
merci je vais je vais essayer de
répondre aux différentes problématiques
qui ont été posées de façon assez
synthétique je l'espère la première
c'est par rapport à l'intervention de
sénatrice d'oiseaux sur au début de
votre propos
j'apprécie beaucoup votre soutien
syndical tel que vous l'avez exprimé je
non non mais sans enfin de façon très
franche et directe comme vous l'avez
fait et je pense que dans la façon
effectivement de travailler les
éléphants les éléments de réforme de
notre pays quel que soit l'enjeu si ce
protection sociale si c'est travail si
c'est parcours professionnel peu importe
la question de du renforcement du
dialogue social et un élément clé nous
semble-t-il sur lequel
enfin on fait beaucoup de benchmark
européens sur les questions de réforme
le dossier de retraite est l'exemple
type du benchmark européen
regardons comment les éléments de
protection sociale ont été construits et
ceux qui sont mis en exergue comment ils
donnent la part en termes de
responsabilité aux différents acteurs
notamment aux acteurs sociaux et la
question du poids des organisations
syndicales et des organisations
employeur vous allez voir après nous
sommes essentiels de ce point de vue là
et y compris pour ne pas trop prolonger
y compris dans cette réforme il y a des
voies à trouver pour renforcer les
éléments de dialogue social ce qu'on
fait comme proposition sur la question
de l'emploi des seniors c'est des
éléments de renforcement du dialogue
social entre nous on n'a pas beaucoup
d'espoir parce que ça fait partie des
éléments de désaccord qui ont provoqué
le rejet de l'index senior à l'Assemblée
et même sans être un grand analyse de ce
qui se passe au Parlement et nous semble
que dans l'équilibre politique qui est
en train de se construire les éléments
de renforcement du dialogue social ont
quand même pas beaucoup de voix d'avenir
sur ce projet de réforme malheureusement
je le dis en toute responsabilité parce
que on ne coûtera pas sur ces questions
névralgiques d'emploi du seigneur de
qualité de carrière si on ne renforce
pas le dialogue social et le chemin qui
est pris à l'Assemblée nationale depuis
hier soir et le chemin inverse à cette
affaire là donc je c'est pour ça que je
le disais de façon très très direct par
rapport à votre propos initial je
développe pas beaucoup parce que
malheureusement la question du
rendez-vous sur comment on peut refonder
de façon un peu plus fondamentale notre
système de retraite ne semble pas être
complètement l'horizon des quelques
semaines qu'ils ont devant nous donc de
ce point-là je vais pas être très très
long cela étant dit un système à points
peut être un système de renforcement de
notre système par répartition il y a une
belle démonstration qui est faite dans
notre pays historiquement c'est il nous
semble que dans les systèmes qui sont
très bien gérés il y a le système de
retraite complémentaire des salariés du
privé agir Arco qui est solide qui est
tenu financièrement et sur lesquels on
peut s'appuyer pour trouver des éléments
de construction à l'avenir et du coup
y compris dans des systèmes à points on
peut trouver des éléments de solidarité
qui permettent de trouver des correctifs
tels que les propos ont été apportés
donc voilà je rentre pas plus
précisément mais de ce qu'on veut dire
par là c'est que le débat actuel en fait
la démonstration si on veut corriger les
questions d'inégalités femmes hommes si
on veut corriger fondamentalement
d'aller au bout de ces logiques là si on
veut corriger une des plus principales
injustices qui est le fait que quand on
est poli pensionné à chaque fois qu'on
change de régime à chaque fois on a une
diminution de calculs de la pension si
on veut quelques y compris sur la
question du minimum de pension si on
veut
avancer fondamentalement sur ces
questions là autrement que en mettant
des rustines on ne pourra le faire que
dans une base de refondation de notre
système de retraite ça ne passera pas
autrement il y a eu trop de réformes qui
ont trop sédimenté la façon dont les
doigts ont droit ont été construits que
désormais quand vous bougez un curseur
vous faites des partager et des
inconvénients et donc du coup c'est ces
éléments là qu'on est en perspective
donc voilà c'est pas c'est pas le
rendez-vous malheureusement qui nous est
proposé cette fois là puisque le choix
était fait de faire un demi-tour à 180
degrés par rapport à ces éléments
d'avenir sur l'usure professionnelle
il y aura pas d'amélioration sur l'usure
professionnelle je
pourrais même modérer un peu votre
propos monsieur Savary c'est sur la
question de l'usure professionnelle il y
a des éléments qui
correspondent à des demandes de la CFDT
c'est l'amélioration du C2P actuel
compte de prévention de la pénibilité
c'est il y a actuellement il y a des
éléments qui sont sur l'abaissement des
seuils qui sont plutôt positifs sur la
question de la prévention on met en
perspective des éléments qui sont plutôt
intéressants le problème c'est que il y
a pas d'amélioration sur la question de
la réparation de l'usure professionnelle
c'est ça le désaccord fondamental de la
CFDT sur ce projet de loi il faut
attendre que le salarié soit cassé avant
de
de prévention non de prévention de
prévention les éléments de prévention
sur les critères ergonomiques et tout
commence à arriver et donc ça va mettre
ça va mettre en place des politiques au
sein des branches qui sont des
politiques d'avenir et la question de la
prévention semble avoir un effet levier
dans ce projet de loi la question c'est
la réparation la question c'est parce
que du coup faut sortir des statistiques
sur ces éléments là c'est quand vous
quand vous travaillez dans une
menuiserie que vous passez votre
carrière à prendre des ventouses pour
porter les les éléments vitrés quand
vous quand vous êtes peintre en bâtiment
que vous portez les sauts de peinture et
que vous êtes systématiquement sur des
postures pénibles ces salariés là c'est
salariés là le projet de réforme il leur
dit soit vous avez un taux d'incapacité
auquel cas vous pouvez partir
deux ans avant les autres mais que à 62
ans quand même que à 72 ans quand même
c'est-à-dire comme aujourd'hui comme
aujourd'hui par contre tous ceux qui ne
sont pas cassés au moment de leur
carrière professionnelle on leur dit
mais vous allez jusqu'à 64 ans et pour
ces salariés là c'est juste
inenvisageable c'est ça le problème de
l'usure professionnelle donc et du coup
si nous si on a une proposition à faire
sur ce thème là la question c'est il
faut que sur les salariés qui sont
exposés aux trois critères
ergonomiques que tout le monde connaît
par cœur maintenant sur ces trois
critères ergonomiques là par des charges
lourdes vibrations mécanique et posture
pénible il faut qu'il bénéficie d'un
droit à la retraite anticipée en
fonction de critères et de seuil qui
auront été définis par les branches
professionnelles et ce système là il est
tout à fait possible à mettre en place
de façon très simple on nous avait
objecté une usine à gaz on a fait des
propositions dans le cas de la
concertation qui qui sur lesquels on
arrive à résoudre les problèmes
originaux qui étaient posés donc
aujourd'hui il y a plus de problèmes de
construction il y a juste une problème
de décision et on sait que ça bloque
uniquement au niveau de la décision et
donc c'est ça qu'on veut obtenir sur la
retraite progressive on est complètement
d'accord avec votre propos c'est il faut
renforcer tous les dispositifs qui
permettent de baisser l'intensité au
travail dans la dernière partie de
carrière c'est comme ça qu'on montera la
qualité de l'emploi dans carrière je
crois qu'on est assez voisin dans la
façon dont vous avez posé la
problématique je suis désolé je suis
désolé ce qui est en train de se monter
en termes de parce que c'est comme ça
que les choses vont se faire ou alors on
n'a pas complètement compris le film
le débat à l'Assemblée nationale montre
que le consensus politique va se faire
sur quelques éléments fondamentaux et
dans les aliments fondamentaux sur
lesquels le consensus politique va se
faire partielle bien sûr c'est le fait
de ne rien faire sur l'emploi des
seniors c'est ça qui est en train de se
mettre en place et donc du coup
l'inverse de l'échange qu'on a ce matin
sur lequel il faut absolument mettre le
paquet pour soutenir la question de la
qualité de l'emploi du seigneurs c'est
ça qui est la voix de passage sur la
forme des retraites et le consensus
politique est en train de se monter et
dont on a eu la démonstration cette nuit
je suis pas en train d'instrumentaliser
le vote de cette nuit la trajectoire qui
est en train de se mettre en place c'est
de vider de sa substance le peu qui a
déjà dans le projet de loi et donc du
coup on va de la problématique qui faut
poser sur l'avenir du système de
retraite j'ai presque fini je réponds
juste ah non j'ai lu pas une question
parce que je pense qu'il faut un débat
de franc et direct sur cette question là
et même en sachant que c'est retransmis
la CFDT ça fait 20 ans ça fait 20 ans
que la CFDT dit il y a une augmentation
de la durée de vie dans le pays cette
augmentation de la durée de vie il faut
la répartir entre la carrière et la
retraite et donc du coup c'est pour ça
qu'on a fait le choix depuis 20 ans de
la durée de cotisation et donc la CFDT
elle n'a jamais remis en cause cette
affaire là et elle ne remet pas en cause
y compris sur le rendez-vous 2023 la
question de la réforme Touraine à 43 ans
de cotisation donc on a un propos qui
est très clair là-dessus je suis sur sur
les perspectives financières en fait
j'ai accès mon propos sur le fait qu'il
y ait un déséquilibre la question de
comment rétablit l'équilibre et très
voisin de ce qui a été dit justement par
mes voisins c'est à dire c'est la
question des recettes qui est posée sur
ce rendez-vous là la question des
recettes nécessite qu'on affine vraiment
quand même ce qui a été construit dans
la perspective de l'équilibre financier
c'est pour ça qu'on insiste lourdement
quand même la perspective de l'emploi
public telle que les choses ont été
calibrées dans le projet de loi nous
sommes quand même être un élément de
confrontation qu'il faut avoir dans ces
balles quoi est-ce que oui ou non on est
dans la perspective de baisser de 10% la
masse salariale la fonction publique
dans notre pays si oui dites comme
donc parce que ça pèse lourdement sur
l'évolution de du financement cette
affaire là donc voilà donc ce débat là
il est pas posé dans les termes que je
viens de le poser la question de la
démographie est posée la question de
l'emploi la qualité de l'emploi et de
l'emploi des seigneurs est posée
merci de leur donner la parole comme a
priori et c'est pour ça que les échanges
sont extrêmement nécessaires se
connaître et changer se rencontrer c'est
se comprendre et c'est comme les monts
ont un sens évidemment
les menaces n'ont pas lieu d'être c'est
une évidence par contre les alertes sont
insistantes et non pas la CGT mais
l'entièreté des organisations syndicales
transmet un communiqué que j'imagine
vous avez lu de près le 7 février qui
est indiqué et qu'un invité le
gouvernement elle est parlementaires à
ne pas être sourd à cette mobilisation
puissante puisque neuf travailleurs sur
10 rejettent cette réforme mais
notamment sur un élément qui est
extrêmement fort pour nous une
démocratie qui fonctionne se doit être à
l'écoute de la position largement
majoritaire de la population qui
s'opposent à cette réforme et à ce titre
nous rappelions toutes et tous ensemble
tous syndicat confondus que lors de
l'examen des projets de loi qui passera
à l'Assemblée au Sénat les
parlementaires doivent prendre leurs
responsabilités en rejeton ce projet de
loi c'est à ce titre là que j'étais
insistant sur le sujet et je n'étais pas
seul à le dire puisque c'est pour ça que
je
j'insiste sur le sujet et que
solennellement toutes les organisations
syndicales salarié de ce pays toutes les
organisations de jeunesse vous alertent
ensemble de sa matière là de cette
manière-là par rapport aux autres
éléments et interpellations extrêmement
intéressantes puisque nous rentrons dans
le vif du débat alors dans nos propres
liminaires les uns et les autres nous
avions donné pas mal d'éléments de notre
point de vue mais évidemment le sujet
c'est d'approfondir première chose non
pas sur la réforme mais sur le
syndicalisme dans son ensemble la
totalité de ce que nous considérons
unanimement là encore des
contre-réformes notamment les dix
ordonnances Macron 2017 qui donne plus
de pouvoir aux directions d'entreprise
et moins de droits à ceux qui
représentent les salariés qui facilitent
les sentiments qui quelqu'un que vous
connaissez ici ce Jacques Toubon qui a
indiqué solennellement par un rapport la
discrimination syndicale que c'est
induisait ce qui participait à la
syndicalisme qu'il faisait reculer et
qui nous a tout et tout ce conduit vous
le savez ici comment ça à raisonner
autour de cette assemblée deux années de
gilets jaunes qui parce que nous n'avons
plus de possibilités de droit pour
défendre les nôtres au quotidien pas sur
les retraites mais le quotidien notre
syndicalisme c'est d'aider d'accompagner
nos collègues de travail au boulot c'est
pas dans le feu des projecteurs c'est
pas dans la rue c'est au quotidien des
centaines de milliers de syndicalistes
quel que soit l'étiquette qu'ils le font
quand ceci est à moiterie on a pu voir
au chapitre et du coup c'est d'autres
sans nous sans représentation qui
partent et sortent dans la rue et vous
l'avez entendu et nous nous souhaiterons
pas que ça se reproduise pourquoi nous
disons cela vous voyez bien quand la
population est aussi massivement opposée
les alertes sont extrêmement fortes et
importantes à ce sujet deuxième élément
sur ce qui a été dit parce que pour nous
c'est
extrêmement important
la France est le deuxième pays au monde
on est champion du monde numéro 2 on est
en finale
de la richesse produite par salarié on
est le deuxième chacun que nous
travaillons et la deuxième heure la plus
productive au monde une la première
européenne et à ce titre-là à titre-là
ça nous induit un deuxième élément c'est
pas les richesses qui sont créées mon
collègue a vous inviter en disant la
part dans les richesses produites la
part qui va au salarié par rapport à
celle qui va à ceux qui détiennent les
entreprises et ben elles font et du coup
la conséquence de ça c'est des salaires
à Moinerie et des petites retraites
troisième élément très important parce
que c'est un sujet nous sommes en France
et vous êtes les représentants de la
République donc des citoyens etc on a
cette chance incroyable d'être le seul
pays au monde où nous n'avons quasiment
plus de retraités pauvre et pourquoi
nous n'avons quasiment plus de roter de
très pauvre ces gaz grâce à notre
système de répartition solidaire mis en
place par le Conseil National de la
Résistance ou tout est tous je le sais
ici nous y sommes très attachés pourquoi
j'insiste sur le sujet c'est parce que
nous sommes l'exception française c'est
celle qui protège si celle qui défend
c'est celle qui compte vaut citoyens
concitoyens viennent vous voir comme
vous me le disiez dans vos dans vos
permanences vous alertes sur les risques
sur l'avenir sur parce que ils sont
conscients de la chance et des du droit
qu'il y a dans ce pays qui n'est pas un
petit sujet et j'insiste sur le fait
dont je comprends sur lequel vous y êtes
très attaché
sur la réforme elle-même les
déséquilibres on est unanime sur le
constat mais unanime parce que il y a du
travail sur le sujet le corps indique
qui peut ou proue
annonce un déficit dans quelques années
de 12 milliards d'euros 12 milliards
d'euros 12 milliards d'euros par rapport
aux pensions qui sont versées chaque
année ces 3% du déficit vous savez les
déficits des ménages incomparable avec
le déficit des retraites et tout autre
le déficit de de l'État est différent le
déficit des entreprises privées et
gigantesques 3% de déficits dans
quelques années eu égard
aux autres déficites que je viens de
citer c'est pour cette raison que comme
le corps comme le président du corps pas
simplement un de ces mondes sans
minimiser ce que ce qu'il est elles sont
indiquent qu'il n'y a pas d'alerte sur
le sujet ce n'est ni ni les
organisations syndicales c'est un
constat partagé par contre nous ne
balayons pas se déficit nous considérons
qu'il faut trouver des solutions parce
qu'à chaque problème trouver une
solution c'est ça organiser la société
comme nous le partageons ici première
élément ça a été dit très fortement
travaillé à l'égalité homme-femme quand
aujourd'hui encore sous un fumeux index
il y a encore 27% de salaire inférieur
pour les femmes que pour les hommes
entendez entendez que que ce sujet est à
travailler et pourquoi il est à
travailler pas simplement pour
l'inégalité subie mais pour les 5,5
milliards ça rapporterait 5,5 milliards
c'est pas la CGT qui le dit la CNAV l'a
dit etc deuxième élément qu'est-ce qu'il
faut résoudre les questions des
déficites prévus je note quand même que
le déficit de 2020 n'a pas été de
celui-ci le déficit 2021 encore moins le
déficit 2022 il est bénéficiaire en
milliards notre régime celui pour lequel
nous sommes ici ainsi à réfléchir à
débattre parce que c'est extrêmement
important plusieurs milliards de
bénéfices en 2022 alors que les
prévisions étaient déficitaires ce n'est
pas grave ce qui est important c'est de
se concentrer au cas où parce qu'il faut
protéger et gouverner ces anticiper et
bien augmenter les salaires augmenter
les cotisations sociales c'est un
élément fondamental qui participe à
réhausser le niveau des retraites et
réhausser le niveau des cotisations pas
beaucoup on demande un peu
revalorisation du SMIC pour vivre
dignement décemment revalorisation
un projet de loi qui est porté en
demande qui n'y est que dès lors que le
SMIC augmente lié à l'inflation il y a
une indexation de tous les minimas de
branches furent juste l'inflation pas
pour gagner plus pour ne pas gagner
moins ça aussi ça amène du salaire et
donc de la cotisation sociale enfin avec
un une symbolique augmentation des
cotisations sociales d'une poignée
d'euros pour quelqu'un qui est au SMIC
pour cotisations dites patronale et
salariale non seulement on est à
l'équilibre mais on peut enfin avoir
quelque chose qui pour nous est
fondamental aucune pension en dessous du
SMIC quand on travaille on a le SMIC
pour travailler pourquoi quand on aurait
retraité on n'y aurait plus droit c'est
une question extrêmement importante et
pour terminer sur le financement il y a
plusieurs dizaines de milliards d'euros
d'exonération de cotisations sociales si
vous ne partagez pas une partie des
éléments que je viens de proposer
j'aimerais savoir lesquels mais c'est un
débat et c'est pour ça que nous sommes
ici pourquoi ne pas conditionner à ceux
qui ne respectent pas qui désemploie les
seniors qui nous licencie avant 60 ans
on peut vous faire des listes par
milliers de salariés qui le subissent
dans lever des exonérations de
cotisation puisque c'est une proposition
que vous souhaitiez à ceux qui ne
respectent pas au moins c'est qu'il
critères là on demande pas plus on
demande les au-delà des paroles et des
éléments de communication la mise en
application
pour terminer puisque nous nous étions
rencontrés il me semble que votre
appréciation exacte que j'avais noté
monsieur Savary quand on s'était
rencontré c'est que la manière dont a
été mise en oeuvre cette loi est deux
effets cumulatifs de Ross de l'âge de
possibilités de départ cumulée à une
accélération de la loi dit Touraine qui
c'est pas jusqu'à 43 ans aujourd'hui ce
qui est ce qui devait être appliqué en
2035 nous sommes en 2023 puisque c'est
enregistré ce serait appliqué accéléré
pour les générations on est après 73
donc il y a bien un effet cumulatif
d'une accélération du nombre de d'années
de cotisations par le bien d'année de
travail pas de chiffres les années les
plus pénibles sont celles de notre fin
de travail les années les meilleurs à la
retraite sont celles des premières
années de retraite pour autant les deux
effets cumulatifs me semblait que votre
appréciation sent surtout déformer vos
propos était nous vous emballez pas
formule poli dernier élément
pour l'ensemble des organisations
syndicales c'est ni 63 années 64 en 62
ans c'est déjà trop vous avez évoqué la
question des carrières longues écoutez
la moitié des actifs aujourd'hui ne sont
plus au travail à 60 ans la moitié il
faut bien solutionner ce qui avant nous
licencie enfin ceux qui nous licencie
avant pour pour pouvoir avancer si on
travaille pas ces questions-là d'égalité
femme de carrière longue de
licenciement de maladies de RSA parce
qu'il faut c'est le sas de précarité qui
augmente il est retraités et dans vos
circonscriptions dans vos permanences
vous devez rencontrer j'imagine des
citoyens dans cet élément qui sont en
train de de décrire
vraiment et dernière puisque là c'était
une question précise je réponds une
réponse précise sur ces régimes
pionniers les régimes les plus
protecteurs il y a l'élément que vous
avancez je le partage je suis au Sénat
je vous alerte une fois de plus quand
des caisses sont excédentaires comme
c'est le cas des énergéticiens par
exemple parce qu'il y a une
surcotisation comme votre régime il y a
une et c'est tout à votre honneur qu'il
soit à l'équilibre on remet en cause des
régimes qui protègent qui sont à
l'équilibre et qui sont efficaces
on pense que c'est pas la piste de
solution que de s'attaquer à ceux qui
sont les plus efficaces plutôt que de
trouver des solutions pour ceux qui
n'ont pas encore de possibilité d'en
bénéficier
merci
sans revenir sans revenir sur ce qui
vient d'être dit puisque je l'avais déjà
précisé nombreux propos liminaire enfin
on sait on sait tous que la retraite
c'est la résultante de la carrière et
que donc la difficulté c'est pas c'est
bien pendant la carrière c'est pas une
fois qu'on arrive à la retraite on peut
réparer mais c'est d'abord travailler
sur les conditions d'emploi d'abord
travailler sur le maintien dans l'emploi
d'abord travailler sur les augmentations
de salaire d'abord travailler sur les
exonérations pour certaines entreprises
dans les conditionnant ça je l'ai déjà
dit je vais répondre à quelques
questions même si je n'ai pas été très
directement
posé j'ai reprendre sur les régies
spéciaux
1 ça a été dit c'est chaud bien souvent
il y a de la surcotisation ou alors il y
a un système de financement qui permet
ok cette tel équilibre je pense à de
notaire par exemple voilà
il y a un système qui permet à ce que le
régime soit soit équilibré pourquoi
pourquoi aller supprimer ce régime voilà
comment explique je comprends pas
vraiment et puis surtout ces régimes ces
régimes ces régimes
ces régimes ils sont ils sont
historiques ils existaient avant 45 et
puis ils font surtout partie du contrat
social de l'entreprise moi je rencontre
assez régulièrement les dirigeants
qu'ils soient de la RATP qu'ils soient
de EDF etc les régimes spéciaux font
partie du contrat social de ces
entreprises ça veut dire que si vous les
supprimez il faudra d'autres
compensations pour les salariés
maintenant il faudra l'inventer ça veut
dire que vous allez entrer dans sur des
des grandes entreprises telles que EDF
GDF tels que la RSTP qu'elle et voilà
sur des compensations et donc
éventuellement sur du conflit social en
interne c'est ça qu'il faut bien avoir
en tête également sur ce qui est sur ce
qui est des des régies spéciaux sur
l'espérance de vie l'espérance de vie
il faut qu'elle soit bien évidemment
pour nous le la plus longue possible en
bonne santé et plus on partage à la
retraite moins on a une espérance de vie
en bonne santé je rappelle quand même
qu'on peut pas oublier aujourd'hui que
l'espérance de vie projetée on n'a pas
pris en compte par exemple et bien les
catastrophes climatiques on a connu des
canicules et les travailleurs qui seront
obligés de travailler dans des
conditions
sous le soleil dans dans des entrepôts
surchauffés et bien cela ils ont une
espérance de vie moindre et que donc il
faut prendre il faut se projeter et il
faut prendre en compte également les
effets de des cris climatique écologique
et climatique
il faut il faut le prendre en compte il
faut l'avoir faut l'avoir en mémoire
voilà et que prolonger la carrière telle
que le gouvernement nous le propose et
bien c'est mettre en danger les
travailleurs enfin sur la retraite
progressive la traite progressive nous
on les favorable alors très progressive
on est même favorable parce que ça soit
la loi puis des accords de branche puis
ensuite éventuellement des des accords
d'entreprise pourquoi pas mais la
retraite progressive ne doit pas faire
baisser la pension du salarié attention
la pension de retraite elle doit être la
même s'il y a des dispositifs de
retraites progressive que si la personne
avait travaillé à temps plein et que
donc il faut penser à des systèmes qui
permettent que cette retraite
progressive et bien qu'au moins les
cotisations elles soient compensées sur
le taux plein pour que le salarié lui
quand il arrive à la retraite et bien il
est une pension
à taux plein comme on dit et voilà
c'est-à-dire que et bien il puisse
bénéficier puisque maintenant c'est
comme ça pour le privé pas pour le
public c'est encore les six derniers
mois mais on voit bien par exemple que à
terme si on se réfère à l'article 1 de
la loi qui a été votée à l'Assemblée
qu'on va plutôt vers un régime unique
dans les années qui viennent et bien
évidemment c'est bien c'est bien la
difficulté la question posée il va
Ricordeau sur la masse salariale dans la
fonction publique il faudra bien qu'on
réponde à la question parce que ça c'est
de la cotisation en moins
le dernier point que que je voulais
évoquer c'est sur le C2P nous aussi on a
fait des propositions et d'ailleurs
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
étaient assez étaient toutes d'accord
pour que faire progresser des plafonner
le C2P reprendre en compte l'ensemble
des critères des critères ergonomiques
nous avions fait aussi une proposition
d'où le C2P des plafonnés plus de 100
points doit permettre de partir à la
retraite plus tôt et il ne doit
permettre que ça à côté de ça il faut
inventer un droit à la transition
professionnelle pour les salariés qui
ont des métiers pénibles pour qu'ils
puissent faire leur deuxième partie de
carrière restez donc en emploi dans des
métiers moins pénibles ça c'est un vrai
droit qui doit exister et qui n'existe
pas aujourd'hui et il y a du financement
il y a du financement il faut un moment
donné responsabiliser aussi les
entreprises dans ce cadre là voilà les
alors sur les carrières longues les 43
ans enfin voilà des 43 ans d'activité
pour mon organisation nous étions posés
à l'époque voilà nous continuons à y
être opposés elle s'applique à tous mais
je rappelle que que à aujourd'hui la
majorité des jeunes rendent sur le
marché du travail après 25 ans enfin
avec un bras en poids je veux dire
quelque chose ou vous cotisez quoi hein
pas un CDD par-ci un CDD par là avec des
petits salaires au SMIC non 25 ans vous
rajoutez 43 on est déjà bien au-delà des
64 ans et que donc reculer l'âge de
départ à la retraite pour le mettre dans
un texte c'est purement inutile et
démagogique
voilà Monsieur mardinet oui bah écoutez
je vais compléter les éléments de Michel
Boga sur l'espérance de vie en
particulier parce qu'on a analysé le
rapport que l'Insee publie tous les 5
ans qui est le rapport sur la
démographie de la France le dernier
étant sorti fin 2021 et finalement
comment l'Insee projette l'espérance de
vie dans le futur et ben c'est un débat
de statisticien sur est-ce que je
prolonge la pente de la droite de des
cinq dernières années des dix dernières
années ou des 20 dernières années et ils
choisissent de prendre un intervalle
relativement long mais c'est pas
justifié par le l'analyse des facteurs
qui réellement influent sur l'évolution
d'espérance de vie ces documenter dans
quelques études dont une étude de l'OCDE
sur la santé dans le monde et l'OCDE
c'est des gens quand même qui
travaillent et les facteurs qui influent
c'est quoi c'est l'état du système de
santé et du système hospitalier c'est le
niveau des pollutions environnementales
de toute nature au nourriture air etc
voir les changements climatiques et si
vous considérez ça et bien
l'espérance de vie notre système
hospitalier je crois que pas grand monde
peut dire qu'il est en très bon état des
gens meurent dans les couloirs aux
urgences maintenant donc
et ben non l'espérance de vie est plutôt
stable et d'ailleurs on avait repris
quels étaient l'espérance de vie prévue
en 2021 dans les projections qui avaient
été faites en 2011
les projections de 2011 étant celles qui
ont servi à la loi Touraine et bien
l'espérance de vie constatée en 2021 et
d'un an inférieur à celle qui était
projetée dans les projections ce qui
veut dire que pour revenir non non non
le covid c'était 2020 l'espérance de vie
2022 elle est au même niveau que celle
de
de 2021 les mêmes inférieurs à celle de
2017 si vous voulez donc non non le
plateau il est pas lié au covid le
plateau qu'on rencontre et donc même
s'il y a eu un pic on est bien d'accord
de mortalité en 2020 et un petit peu en
2021 et donc voilà les facteurs sont pas
objectifs et on peut même dire que la
loi Touraine l'esprit de la loi Touraine
c'était comme la rappeler
Ivan mais sans mettre les chiffres
c'était on alloue deux tiers des gains
d'espérance de vie à la vie active et un
tiers à la retraite c'était ça ce qui
avait été dit à l'époque ça veut dire
que si on s'appuyait sur l'espérance de
vie constatée par rapport à ce qu'elle
était projetée dans le rapport de 2011
qui a servi à la base mais il faudrait
s'arrêter à 42 ans bon bon alors c'est
pas le débat actuel on dit ok c'est
comme ça mais si on prenait en compte
ces éléments on devrait même s'arrêter à
42 ans donc vous voyez que ces données
d'espérance de vie de même que quand
vous prenez l'avion vous atterrissez à
Orly je sais pas ben si le pilote a eu
des prévisions météo qui lui prévoyaient
du beau temps vous espérez que s'il y a
du brouillard il va quand même
actualiser sa pratique et pas se poser
comme s'il y avait beau temps s'il y a
du bruit donc bah là c'est pareil faut
actualiser et prendre en compte les
facteurs qui influent et pas uniquement
des projections statistiques qui ne sont
pas réalistes et d'ailleurs
Hervé Le Bras de Linette il a bien
souligné lui-même et lui c'est un expert
démographe donc voilà
le deuxième point sur lequel je voulais
intervenir bon sur la pénibilité bien
sûr il faut s'améliorer moi je vous ré
souligner ça avait été déjà fait et en
particulier sur la disponibilité
psychique qui croit fortement et
d'ailleurs qui influe sur les contes de
l'assurance maladie parce qu'il y a de
plus en plus d'arrêt de travail quand
les gens arrivent fatigués en fin de
carrière
usé psychologiquement qui ne trouve plus
de sens dans leur travail et ça faudra
bien le considérer aussi dans la
pénibilité parce que beaucoup de nos
concitoyens qui ont des fonctions
d'encadrement vu que nous on adresse
plutôt ce public là ben considère que le
projet de loi avec l'augmentation de
l'âge c'est un projet de loi liberticide
c'est-à-dire moi si j'ai plus de sens
dans mon boulot si je suis fatigué je
veux garder la possibilité de partir
même si j'ai pas tout mes trimestres et
ça c'est vécu dans l'encadrement comme
un projet de loi liberticide un jeu et
si on a autant de mobilisation dans les
Russes et essentiellement pour ça après
moi je voudrais vous alerter aussi alors
c'est Monsieur ça va monsieur monsieur
Savary qui l'a dit mais il faut pas
réduire un système de retraite
comme étant sensible à un seul facteur
bon le facteur nombre d'actifs sur
nombre le ratioactif retraité est
souvent cité comme un élément important
je suis d'accord c'est un élément
important et on le voit bien sur la
fonction publique ou ce ratioactif
retraité fonction publique d'État est
inférieure à maintenant parce qu'il y a
plus d'embauche au statut etc voilà et
donc si un problème de recettes dans nos
systèmes de retraite il est
essentiellement du côté du fait que
l'État ne finance pas correctement et
donc est un gestionnaire de très
mauvaise qualité de la retraite des
salariés dont il a la responsabilité et
pour ça s'il y a un problème de de
recettes au niveau de l'État bah c'est
pas à tous les salariés de travailler
deux ans de plus pour fournir vers cet
état c'est à l'état de mobiliser toutes
ces recettes et nous on en appelle en
particulier à avoir un meilleur partage
de la valeur qui ferait rentrer plus de
7 dans les caisses de l'état de la part
des grandes entreprises qui et puis de
traiter enfin le sujet de l'évasion
fiscale et de la fraude fiscal qui
ramènerait un grand nombre de ressources
dans les caisses de l'État plutôt que de
demander aux gens de travailler plus
pour que ça continue à amplifier
l'évasion fiscale donc ça nous et on
voit bien on est sa pénalise fortement
les salariés les travailleurs et sur un
problème d'exemplarité moi j'en appelle
quand même à un point vous savez qui
existe des retraites chapeau pour les
dirigeants d'entreprises et ça on en a
nous on aimerait bien parce que quand on
dit ah bah il y a des hautes retraites
bah oui bah quelqu'un qui touche une
retraite de 4000 euros ou 4500 euros
parce qu'il a une une carrière avec une
forte rémunération c'est pas lui qu'il
faut venir amputer la retraite il faut
augmenter les petites retraites en
entièrement d'accord mais j'attire en
particulier votre
attention sur ce qu'on appelle l'article
82 par référence à l'article 82 du CGI
qui est un dispositif de retrait de
chapeau beaucoup utilisé en entreprise
et où finalement les entreprises vu que
c'est un dispositif ou l'imposition se
fait entrer les entreprises payent
propos des dirigeants si vous voulez
donc on offre moi j'appelle c'est
quasiment de la butte bien social ça
quand vous avez une entreprise et qui
pendant ce temps là et ben elle ne sait
pas de l'argent qui va dans les
investissements pour créer de l'emploi
en France et pas de l'argent qui va pour
rémunérer les salariés et donc moi
j'aimerais bien que ce sujet là soit
abordé parce que c'est vraiment un
dispositif scandaleux
bien alors mais chers collègues nous
avons 12 questions
12 questions donc nous allons prendre
les douze question à suivre et enfin les
12 collègues à suivre et je demanderai à
nos intervenants de répondre brièvement
sur des points particuliers mais je vous
demande de faire des questions concises
parce qu'à 11 heures nous avons en
principe les organisations patronales
donc des questions consistent ce n'est
pas la peine forcément de répéter ce que
vient de dire le collègue des questions
très précises et très concises même si
je sais que le sujet est très important
et nous aurait fallu sans doute plus de
temps néanmoins c'est ainsi victoire
jasmin
merci oui merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente merci Monsieur pour les
informations que vous avez transmises
alors moi je vais parler des
outre-merdes et particulièrement de la
Guadeloupe
en outre-mer il y a un fort taux de
chômage des jeunes et il y a une grande
majorité de femmes qui travaillent pas
qui sont chômage et celle qui travaille
ont des carrières qui sont chaotiques je
dirais donc vous avez illustré par vos
propos des situations qui sont que vous
connaissez et j'ai même entendu qu'il y
avait pas en France des retraites et
pauvres alors que je fus présidente de
CCAS et beaucoup de femmes retraitées
ont des difficultés pour garder leur
loyer pour payer leur loyer pour garder
leur logement et pour payer leurs
factures alors je voudrais également
savoir ce que vous pensez du chômage des
jeunes alors est-ce que en prolongeant
le nombre d'amitié pour les personnes
qui travaillent et qui malheureusement
n'ont pas forcément une retraite décente
est-ce que les jeunes doivent payer
justement en étant au chômage en ayant
évidemment des
contrats des contrats saisonniers ou
quelquefois carrément rien du tout
ils sont malheureusement dans des
situations de violence quelquefois c'est
du trafic de toutes sortes y compris de
drogues qui leur permet de faire des
choses indécentes illicite alors moi je
ne voudrais qu'on puisse réfléchir aussi
pour les jeunes parce qu'on parle des
aînés des seniors c'est vrai travailler
plus longtemps c'est le choix du
gouvernement mais moi je suis très
inquiète pour ces territoires là et
particulièrement pour la Guadeloupe
merci
très bien Monique Lubin ensuite ce sera
vraiment de penser bon j'ai encore une
merci madame la Présidente bon je vais
éviter tous les commentaires que j'ai
envie de faire pour pas rallonger on les
frappe pendant le débat donc
monsieur ricordo vous avez un préambule
fait une comparaison avec la période qui
était celle de la réforme Touraine en
disant qu'effectivement les les le
comment dire le la situation financière
à l'époque des régimes de retraite
n'était pas du tout celle que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui ce que vous avez
des éléments un peu plus précis à nous
donner deuxième question
le système des carrières longues est
maintenu mais il est modifié quelqu'un
qui a commencé à travailler à 18 ans
devra travailler jusqu'à 62 ans et non
plus jusqu'à 60 ans c'est donc là qu'on
peut trouver des gens qui auront 44
annuités la première ministre dit on va
remédier à ça de quelle façon est-ce que
est-ce qu'il y sera remédier est-ce que
ces gens là pourront partir à 61 ans ce
qu'il y a des discussions à ce sujet
et où on sent ces discussions
troisième chose troisième alors c'est
toujours pour Monsieur Ricordeau vous
avez été franc je serai franchement
aussi
la question de de l'emploi des seniors
elle est évidemment primordiale c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs que moi je dis qu'il
s'agit pas d'un projet de réforme des
retraites mais juste effectivement d'une
loi de finances parce qu'on aurait dû
commencer par parler de travail avant de
parler retraites mais on en débattra
ce qui s'est passé hier soir à
l'Assemblée nationale effectivement vous
avez l'air bon de le regretter en
considérant que c'est comment dire une
erreur puisque du coup il y aura plus
rien dans la réforme des retraites
concernant l'emploi des seniors mais si
ça s'est passé comme ça c'est parce que
de toute façon ce qui était prévu ce qui
est prévu dans la réforme tout le monde
le sait que ça ou rien c'est à peu près
pareil tout le monde de sait qu'un index
ça ne sert à rien d'ailleurs on a qu'à
voir ce qui se passe en matière
d'égalité salariale homme-femme par
exemple il y a eu plein d'index plein de
machins plein de trucs bon bah
finalement il se passe toujours la même
chose et des lois qui ne sont pas
respectées donc on peut regretter ce qui
s'est passé hier soir mais effectivement
le dialogue social il se passe pas à
l'Assemblée nationale au Sénat le
dialogue social il se passe par des non
pas des concertations mais des
négociations avec les syndicats est-ce
que vous penchez pas que c'est plutôt
est-ce que vous ne pensez pas que c'est
plutôt là que ça a péché
bien évidemment plutôt côté gouvernement
je ne remets pas en question la volonté
de débattre des syndicats je vais
m'arrêter là j'aurais plein d'autres
questions à poser mais on verra ça plus
tard
vraiment de penser mon je brièvement
également brièvement il me le rappelle
grande crainte
moi j'aimerais que toutes les
organisations syndicales me très
rapidement me répondent sur le bilan qui
font quand même des réformes précédentes
et notamment du passage de 60 à 62 ans
car quand même cette réforme ou des
annuités on nous l'a vendu un petit peu
enfin certains ont été pour certains ont
été compte mais pour ces fameux critères
de pénibilité alors je reviens pas sur
le fait qu'on en a enlevé 4 remis 3 en
ergonomique mais quand même c'est bien
beau cela mais si vous regardez des
statistiques quand même
les critères de pénibilité sont tous
dans une tendance d'aggravation que vous
preniez tous les critères d'exposition
d'exposition aux risques les contrats et
risques physiques à partir de trois
contraintes l'intensité du travail la
contrainte de temps la contrainte de
rythme la CFDT en a parlé qui font
effectivement les risques aussi
psychosociaux tout cela ils explosent
d'un année et donc on fait une réforme
en disant on donnera deux ans à ceux qui
deux ans maximum et maintenant 62 ans à
ceux qui sont exposés sans critiquer
sans aucune critique du fait que
l'évolution tendancielle elle est à de
plus en plus où il y avait une
contrainte physique il y en a trois une
contrainte de rythme c'est avec sans
autonomie tout ça donc vraiment
qu'est-ce que vous avez vu avec avec je
dis bien maintenant le CHSCT qui a été
supprimé moi j'insiste beaucoup sur le
CHSCT qui explique peut-être aussi cette
exposition
de plus de plus en plus forte car enfin
répartir entre la carrière et la
retraite enfin aujourd'hui c'est pas le
cas la durée de la retraite baisse
c'est-à-dire que non seulement on a
bouloté les gains d'espérance de vie
mais on a pris sur l'espérance de vie en
bonne santé donc je crois qu'il faut moi
j'aimerais vous entendre
qu'est-ce que vous avez vu 60-62 enfin
et ça affaiblit aussi des faits
redistributifs de la retraite vous
qu'est-ce que vous vous avez vu et
comment si vous voulez partir du moment
où les conséquences ont été aussi graves
de 60 à 62 ans on peut effectivement
oser penser 62 64 qui sera avec des
effets beaucoup plus durs une Ferrari
merci messieurs merci madame la
Présidente à mon tour de vous interroger
sur la pénibilité de deux questions vous
l'avez rappelé donc quatre critères sur
qui ont été supprimés en 2017
aujourd'hui dans ce projet de loi
rectificatif le gouvernement propose de
réintégrer j'ai mis des guillemets trois
critères ou c'est pas réintégrer c'est
pour ça que j'ai mis des guillemets non
mais c'est pour ça que j'ai bien dit de
réintégrer avec des énormes guillemets
parce que c'est aussi leur communication
trois de ces quatre critères les trois
critères ergonomiques mais rien sur les
risques chimiques donc que pensez-vous
de cette proposition quel est votre avis
sur cette proposition de la même façon
l'autre question quel est votre avis sur
la proposition de mise en place d'un
fond le fipu le fond d'investissement
pour la prévention de l'usure
professionnelle voilà que pensez-vous de
cette proposition
très bien Katia pour ce Boli
merci madame la Présidente alors moi je
ne vais pas revenir sur tout le bien que
je pense de cette réforme avec l'horos
Cohen nous aurons le temps évidemment en
séance de d'essayer de démontrer avec
les amendements que nous déposerons et
bien évidemment
bien évidemment pourquoi cette réforme
est profondément injuste et ça a été dit
par les syndicats profondément injuste
pour les femmes et profondément injuste
pour les salariés et les ouvriers qui
peinent le plus parce que finalement
la question est bien elle est celle-ci
moi je voudrais féliciter les
organisations syndicales
parce que il y a quand même des millions
des milliers dans toutes les villes dans
des petites villes parfois moi je le
vois chez moi à Saint-Omer 4000
personnes dans une petite ville
féliciter les organisations syndicales
parce que il n'y a pas de débordement
les manifestations alors qu'il y a des
millions de personnes dans la rue et
bien se passe bien
sans aucun débordement et nous n'avons
ici enfin pour ma part ni à souffrir les
uns les autres d'agression ou quoi que
ce soit je préfère qu'on se dit les
choses parce que parfois on a tendance à
dire bon voilà mais là franchement pas
du tout tout on a connu pire avec
d'autres projets de loi donc en tous les
cas je tenais à le dire voilà alors moi
je voudrais vous poser juste trois
questions puisque le temps nous est
compté et qu'on va pouvoir le faire ici
même si je pense que la méthode n'est
pas la même puisque nous avons à faire
il faut se le dire à un 49-3 déguisé
c'est ce que nous pensons avec cette
réforme des retraites moi je voudrais
savoir si si vous enfin si vous pouvez
répondre à cette question peut-être pas
là tout de suite parce que finalement je
demande des chiffres mais avez-vous des
chiffres précis sur l'espérance de vie
parce qu'il y a l'espérance de vie en
bonne santé en bonne santé entre les
professions et entre les milieux sociaux
qui sont différents parce que on lit des
choses mais j'aimerais si vous le pouvez
donner des chiffres on parle euros brut
on entend tout et n'importe quoi et
d'ailleurs le gouvernement n'est pas en
capacité aujourd'hui de nous répondre
sur le nombre de personnes qui
toucheront les 1200 euros avez-vous pour
votre part un chiffre et nous
communiquer et j'aimerais savoir
finalement en moyenne de combien de
combien
les personnes donc seront-ils augmentées
et j'ai une troisième question si vous
me permettez la prise en compte de la
pénibilité
sera
comment dire sera prise
la pensez-vous que le report de l'âge va
compter et créer de nouvelles personnes
finalement en situation de précarité
j'arrête parce que j'avais encore cinq
ou six questions sur la précarité mais
c'est pas la et sur
surtout la pénibilité ou les quand même
Emmanuel Macron avait déjà remis les
critères de pénibilité en cause
puisqu'il avait remis quatre critères de
pénibilité en cause merci
je suis désolé
merci madame la Présidente
donc de questions pour moi d'abord
davantage de dialogue social avant les
projets de loi notamment sur le travail
des seniors que vous avez tous évoqué et
je pense que ça aurait été beaucoup plus
fructueux avant ce projet de loi pour
pour mettre en place donc ce projet de
loi et travailler d'abord avant sur les
emplois seniors puisque nous sommes les
plus mauvais au niveau de l'Europe donc
deux questions quelles solutions pour la
retraite progressive elle travaille
partiel quelle solution pour inciter les
PME à conserver les seniors d'abord
incitation fiscale
ou sanction et aussi au niveau de la
pénibilité
monsieur de la CGT a indiqué tout à
l'heure par exemple que les aides
soignantes les infirmières
ne pouvaient pas aller jusqu'à 64 ans je
suis d'accord c'est quand ça va être
considéré comme un travail pénible et
selon vous qui doit mettre en place les
critères pour la qualification de
travail pénible voilà merci
bien Frédéric puissant ensuite Alain
Dufour uniquement levier nous Martinique
Christine je vais tout de suite à ma
question merci pour vos interventions
madame la Présidente simplement nous
avons un certain nombre de nos collègues
députés conduits par notre collègue
Philippe Juvin qui propose de mettre en
place un régime additionnel et
d'introduire une part de capitalisation
dans le système quel est votre avis
Alain Dufour
oui merci
messieurs les intervalles les
représentants syndicaux juste une
question aussi rapidement il a fait il a
été fait état de du travail des seniors
et on sait qu'en France il y a seulement
33 % des seniors qui sont embauchés bon
quels sont les incitations que vous
voyez pour les entreprises pour
permettre l'emploi de ces seniors
premier point nous dire pourquoi il
faudrait qu'on s'y sur le projet de loi
il se soit clarifié les 1200 euros par
mois car on parle de 1200 euros si vous
voulez net et 85 % du SMIC ça fait pas
le compte donc je voudrais avoir vos
éléments là-dessus merci
oui merci madame la Présidente oui je
voulais rapidement aussi vous
questionnez messieurs sur l'emploi des
seniors et sur l'égalité du salaire
femme homme puisque vous avez dit que en
rencontrant nos trois rapporteurs que
dont je salue d'ailleurs
l'investissement et le travail sur un
texte qui est quand même très technique
vous aviez donné des pistes et j'aurais
bien aimé connaître les pistes sur
lesquels que vous envisagez merci
Olivier c'est nous oui merci madame la
Présidente merci messieurs d'abord un
juste un constat rapide je crois qu'on a
la démonstration tous les jours que on
peut pas engager une réforme sociale de
cette ampleur sans un pari charisme fort
et la question qui va être la nôtre
c'est comment on va renforcer le
paritariste dans les années à venir
maintenant trois questions très
très pointu la première sur la question
de la pénibilité vous l'avez évoqué mais
ce qu'on a pas quand même un regard un
peu
passéiste sur la pénibilité et vous
l'avez abordé sur la question psychique
la pénibilité elle existe pour un
ouvrier mais encore qu'avec la
robotisation parfois un peu moins
qu'autre fois tant mieux mais elle
existe aussi pour un professeur qui est
dans l'enseignement dans un collège ou
dans un lycée difficile et finalement il
y a pas beaucoup de voix qu'on entend
sur sur ce sujet deuxième question sur
l'index senior feu l'index seniors mais
enfin tout de même aborder cette
question est-ce que
quelque chose qui tomberait autour d'un
bonus malus pour être une idée selon
vous très très très précisément et
troisième question sur la politique
familiale j'ai la conviction moi que on
est aidé accompagner dans beaucoup de
choses dans notre société aujourd'hui
finalement encore assez peu
pour avoir un enfant pour éduquer un
enfant et donc la question du
renouvellement des générations est posée
et pensez-vous que
en matière de politique familiale la
majoration de pensions pourrait être une
incitation et et et
quelque chose de concret pour faciliter
une vraie politique familiale parce que
il y a des interrogations est-ce qu'il
faut aider ou gratifier les gens plus
tard ou est-ce qu'il faut les aider au
moment où ils ont des enfants avez-vous
un regard sur cette question je vous
remercie Martin lévrier merci madame la
Présidente quelques questions qui sont
importantes pour bien comprendre le
problème parce que on a un problème
d'équilibre malgré tout du régime des
retraites alors en jouant sur certains
curseurs je l'ai entendu tout à l'heure
on dit que finalement il y aura
peut-être pas de déficit est-ce que
finalement et ça rejoint la
problématique des seigneurs si
finalement on dit que le taux de chômage
est très bas dans le choix qu'on va
faire de calcul
indirectement on inclut une embauche
enfin une prolongation longue des
seigneurs de l'entreprise si le taux de
chômage est de 5% je crois que
d'ailleurs le corps son analyse sur une
base de l'ordre de 5% de chômage quelque
part ça veut dire que les seniors
restent dans l'entreprise et que les
jeunes sont plutôt actifs 5% de chômeurs
donc une fois qu'on prend ce critère là
le débat sur les seniors est un autre
débat selon moi et si on est sur 5%
malgré un déficit comme on fait pour
avoir plus de recettes c'est-à-dire
plus de recettes sachant qu'on n'aura
pas plus d'actifs quelle est la bonne
solution
j'ai entendu aussi augmenter les
cotisations donc c'est baisser le
pouvoir d'achat moi j'ai pas oublié que
quand on a enlevé 5 euros de cotisation
d'appel ça a été la fin du monde donc
augmenter les cotisations me paraît pas
aujourd'hui dans la dans la
problématique du pouvoir d'achat une
bonne solution donc quelles sont les
solutions que vous proposez par rapport
à ça si on part du principe que le taux
de chômage et de l'ordre 5% du plein
emploi donc qui dit pleine emploi dit
pas de problématique seniors mais je ne
nie pas que la problématique Seigneur
existe un jeu de l'année absolument pas
on dit que c'est l'analyse le curseur
qui est posé là puis une deuxième
question qui est la dernière quand je
regarde la France n'est pas une île
quand je regarde les autres pays
d'Europe je me rends compte que nous
sommes un des pays qui a le l'âge de
départ à la retraite le plus bas c'est
très bien en soi mais qu'est-ce qui fait
qu'on est meilleur que les autres
comment vous analysez le fait qu'on soit
bien meilleur que les autres sur ce
sujet là puisque l'Italie est prêt à
monter à 69 ans alors que ce sont nos
voisins les plus proches merci beaucoup
et pour terminer Christine Bonfanti de
ça alors lorsqu'on arrive presque enfin
les questions sont un peu redondantes
moi j'ai trois points rapides
vous avez beaucoup parlé d'espérance de
vie mais pas ou peu de natalité alors
que la question de la de la politique
familiale et fondamentale lorsqu'on sait
qu'il faut plus de 20 ans pour un jeune
pour qu'il contribue à ce système de
répartition auquel vous êtes très
attaché qu'est-ce que vous pouvez me
dire sur cela la pénibilité donc je
redis que effectivement il y a des
critères qui ont été enlevés est-ce
qu'il faut aujourd'hui les réhabiliter
et plus particulièrement je pense à
l'exposition au risque chimiques et puis
pour finir à travailler égal salaire
égal c'est ce qui est inscrit dans la
loi du 4 août 2014 pour qui pour une
égalité réelle entre les hommes et les
femmes donc
2014-2023 comment expliquer vous alors
la situation qui nous occupe aujourd'hui
très bien merci à mes collègues qui ont
été
obéissance à mes consignes un peu oui
non c'est pas rare aux États-Unis
d'être quand même un peu maîtresse
d'école
genre de débat et je laisse monsieur
Ricordeau on regarde toujours le même
ordre ok ma chérie
je sais pas si les quatre syndicalistes
vont être obéissants mais au moins dans
les rêves au moins dans les règles du
jeu on va enfin je vais pas répondre à
l'ensemble des questions on va pas on va
on se répartir sans doute pour essayer
de les traiter dans le temps qui est un
parti
sur différentes questions qui ont été
qui ont été posées le comparatif je vais
le faire très rapidement mais le
comparatif par rapport aux réformes
précédentes c'est aujourd'hui le débat
public aujourd'hui pas sur les discords
peu importe le débat public parle de aux
alentours d'un besoin de financement de
10 milliards d'euros par an 2014 le même
débat public point un enjeu financier
aux alentours d'une trentaine de
milliards d'euros trois fois plus
important en 2010 quand il y a eu la
réforme Fillon il y avait une
perspective financière aux alentours de
50 milliards d'euros 5 fois plus
important et 2014 2010 systématiquement
les projections prévoyaient des systèmes
financiers en chute libre derrière le
besoin à court terme que je viens de
libérer donc aujourd'hui on est à 10
milliards d'euros et une perspective de
stabilisation de l'équilibre financier à
terme donc c'est ça les pures voilà et
la question qui est la question qui est
posée c'est pourquoi alors qu'on est
dans l'horizon financier le moins dur
pourquoi on a la réforme la plus brutale
c'est ça la question qui est posée et la
question qui est derrière cette affaire
là mais qui mais qui est un vrai débat
politique et qui a un vrai débat public
le la question qui est derrière c'est
que en fait la réforme et le PLFSS qui
est proposé n'est pas une question de
règlement du problème financier des
systèmes de retraite c'est une question
d'ajustement des finances publiques
c'est ça la question qui est derrière
mais c'est une question qui
politiquement peut venir dans un pays
quel qu'il soit et le nôtre on avait on
avait un déficit public qui était
important il y a une politique publique
de soutien à l'économie pendant la crise
covid qui est tout à fait justifiée sur
l'ONU mais qui a encore dégradé les
finances publiques et donc la question
de comment rétablit les finances
publiques il y a un vrai débat politique
a mené dans ce pays-là la seule question
pour la CFDT qui est imprenable c'est
qu'on ne peut pas rétablir les finances
publiques uniquement en ajustant la
protection sociale des travailleurs
alors c'est ça le choix politique qui
est fait dans la période actuelle on a
commencé par l'assurance chômage on
continue par les retraites et donc il
est pas question que on ne touche pas la
fiscalité que l'on touche pas on ne
regarde pas la question des aides aux
entreprises qui sont des autres éléments
importants de dépenses publiques et que
puisqu'on ne veut pas toucher à la
fiscalité puisqu'on ne veut pas changer
le mode opératoire en termes de
conditionnalité pour les aides publiques
qu'est-ce qu'on fait et ben on a juste
la protection sociale c'est ça le débat
derrière et c'est pas le débat sur le
financement du système de retraite en
premier qui est posé donc voilà pour la
première partie sur les carrières
longues sur les carrières je vais pas
répondre précisément on sait ce qui
s'est on connaît les annonces on a lu le
phrasé de la première ministre hier à
l'Assemblée nationale il y a pas la
possibilité d'avoir quelques éléments
d'analyse si on n'a pas le futur décret
il y a rien dans la loi sur les
carrières longues dans la loi il y a
juste besoin de mettre des bandages et
encore même ce qu'il y avait dans la loi
aujourd'hui est suffisant tout se
réglera par décret derrière donc il faut
absolument dans le débat qui a lieu
actuellement sur l'ajustement des
dispositifs avoir la transparence du
futur décret s'il y a pas ça c'est
impossible de dire est-ce que c'est
plutôt positif ou plutôt négatif la
mesure qui est proposée et combien de
salariés seront concernés par les
annonces qui ont été effectuées en
fonction de quels critères si vous
n'avez pas le décret vous avez rien en
termes de connaissances on a trop
navigué dans la concertation qu'on a eu
avec le ministère du travail sur des
éléments oraux sur les carrières longues
à enfin on a dit si vous nous mettez pas
sur la table des tableaux qui nous
disent comment évoluent ce dispositif là
et ben on y arrivera pas et bah vous
avez la même chose Assemblée nationale
et Sénat sur le dispositif carrière
longue si vous avez pas un truc carré
avec l'ensemble des critères l'ensemble
des tableaux qui vous dit comment les
choses vont évoluer il y a enfin pour
nous c'est impossible de se prononcer
donc pour l'instant c'est trop vague et
c'est un truc particulièrement important
pour la CFDT c'est nous qui sommes à
l'origine de ce dispositif là et on a on
est on s'est beaucoup on est beaucoup
intervenus pour vérifier comment les
choses allaient évoluer vous voyez la
difficulté dans laquelle on se situe et
j'ai cru comprendre que l'annonce d'hier
à l'Assemblée nationale provoque le même
élément de demande de clarification pour
savoir exactement qu'est-ce qui bouge ou
ça bouge dans quel sens ça bouge et à
quelle hauteur ça bouge quoi bah voilà
on a résumé la question sur ce
dispositif là je il me reste deux points
sur lesquels intervenir sur l'index sur
l'index ce que je veux dire c'est moi
j'ai enfin on a été alerté par rapport à
ce qui s'est passé conseillère pas tant
que ça a été repoussé ou pas repoussé on
a enfin l'index c'est un outil c'est pas
l'index qui va faire la politique de
l'emploi du Seigneur dans le pays donc
là dessus on n'a pas des Data d'âme le
seul élément qui enfin le seul élément
l'élément d'inquiétude de la CFDT c'est
que l'article 2 a été repoussé parce que
je suis désolé je le dis tel que moi je
l'ai compris je peux me tromper parce
que les républicains ou une partie des
républicains se sont positionnés pour
dire on est contre le fait de baisser le
seuil à des entreprises à 50 salariés et
on est contre le fait de renforcer la
négociation d'entreprise quand l'index
va pas dans le bon sens et donc
une partie et une partie des
de la majorité c'est aussi positionner
dans ce sens là ce qui veut dire qu'on
avait déjà un dispositif index senior
qui n'était pas la nature d'avoir une
politique de l'employé seniors mais en
plus on a un refus nous on regarde ça
dans la perspective du débat au Sénat ou
sur lesquels on fera tout le monde a
compris le film qui pouvait se passer
quoi et donc du coup le seul qui peut se
passer selon nous à l'avenir c'est que
la politique de l'employeur qui était
déjà pas très ambitieuse dans le projet
initial dans le cadre de la concertation
on essayait de le renforcer on a formulé
des amendements qui permettaient d'aller
plus loin sur le dialogue social plus
loin sur les plus loin sur tout cela est
détricoté au fur et à mesure il y avait
déjà pas la politique de l'emploi des
seniors on va avec quoi on va se
retrouver au sortir des Sénats sur cette
politique là c'était ça le le propos que
je tenais tout à l'heure sur la
pénibilité sur la pénibilité il y a
quatre critères qui ont été sortis en
2017 il y a un critère sur les agents
chimiques dangereux ça c'est d'une autre
nature que les trois autres tout
simplement parce que c'est très on
l'admet au niveau de la CFDT c'est
compliqué sur ce sur ce critère là sur
les agences chimiques dangereux de
calculer comment chaque salarié est
exposé en fonction et c'est plutôt et on
a convenu dans la discussion avec le
ministère du Travail on est transparent
et on est on est enfin on n'a pas de
discours différents au niveau du Sénat
qu'on l'a nationale qu'on l'a dans la
rue et qu'on l'a avec le ministère du
Travail on dit la même chose on a
convenu avec le ministère du Travail que
sur les agents chimiques dangereux
c'était une vraie question de
législation pour protéger les
travailleurs sur les normes des agents
chimiques dangereux et que c'était
compliqué de le faire rentrer dans le
compte pénibilité position de la CFDT
affirmer comme ça voilà par contre sur
les trois critères ergonomiques par des
charges lourdes
vibration mécanique et postures pénible
ils ont été sortis en 2017 ces trois
critères ergonomiques provoquent 95% des
troubles musculo-squelettiques dans le
monde du travail aujourd'hui donc
ceux-là ils sont névralgiques en termes
de conditions de travail et de
réparation de la pénibilité cela le
gouvernement le ministère du Travail et
la première ministre ne veulent pas les
voir réintégrer le compte le compte de
prévention de la pénibilité le C2P pour
et donc pourquoi ils ne veulent pas ils
ne veulent pas sur un marqueur politique
qui est de pas le remettre dans le à
l'origine et en faisant ça ils
interdisent la réparation pour les
salariés pour qu'il bénéficie en
fonction de critères de dispositif de
départ anticipé à la retraite c'est ça
c'est ça c'est là-dessus qu'on a une
opposition quoi et donc ce que
revendique la CFDT c'est sur ces trois
qualités là il faut les remettre dans le
compte de prévention de la pénibilité
c'est ça qu'on prenne professionnelle de
prévention de la pénibilité c'est ça
qu'il faut faire sur les 1200 euros je
finis là-dessus j'ai juste une petite
touche pas je peux pas m'empêcher je
vous passe la parole derrière je sur le
benchmark européen sur le benchmark
européen là-dessus enfin auquel les
grandes images on peut se les passer les
uns après les autres moi j'ai la
responsabilité européenne au niveau de
la CFDT aussi en même temps quand je
discute avec les syndicalistes européens
il se passe deux choses c'est en France
faut pas oublier qu'on a deux critères
l'âge de la retraite il est à 67 ans
l'âge d'ouverture des droits il est à 62
ans aujourd'hui et la mécanique a
fonctionne sur ces deux éléments là et
donc le truc du benchmark européen
uniquement sur la retraite à 62 ans
c'est facile de le faire mais la réalité
est pas celle-là parce que en France le
départ moyen a dépassé l'âge d'ouverture
des droits et quand vous discutez avec
les syndicats listes européens vous
savez ce qui se passe il se passe que
les Français disent nous on a
l'ouverture des droits au-delà de 62 ans
et on est en train de prolonger après
les 62 ans et tous les Européens vous
disent nous on a la retraite à cet
âge-là et les salariés font le choix de
décoder ils partent avant c'est ça la
réalité et donc nous on a une réalité
qui dépasse le critère et eux ils ont
une réalité qui anticipe le critère donc
faut y aller faut faire attention il
faut faire attention à ce qui se passe
au niveau européen on est sur on est sur
la continuation de l'augmentation de la
durée d'activité comme les autres pays
Européens on n'a pas choisi parce qu'on
est en France et qu'on a un système de
répartition en France qui a une histoire
et vous allez discuter en Belgique aller
discuter en Belgique dans l'indexation
des salaires vous allez voir ce qui se
passe par rapport à ce qui se passe en
France sur la revalorisation des
salaires chacun une histoire sociale qui
a qui a construit notre système
donc pour Monsieur Vacheron merci
beaucoup pour compléter alors d'abord
puisque c'était un des sujets la
question du comparatif européen puisque
ça vient d'être fait nous on rappelle
solennellement que en France toutes les
organisations syndicales sont opposées à
ce projet vous l'avez bien compris mais
en Europe aussi on a un soutien unanime
de toutes les organisations syndicales
européennes qui soutiennent la
mobilisation et la revendication des
syndicats de salariés de ce pays c'est
important que que l'organisation qui
rassemble le plus de population en
Europe les organisations syndicales soit
raccord avec nous et nous soutiennent
sur les questions très précises que vous
avez posées la question des bilans des
contre-réformes précédentes celle de
1993 qui inflige pendant l'été au privé
de passer des 10 moins mauvaises années
au 25 moins meilleures années c'est plus
de 20% de pension en moins pour les
salariés du privé 22 millions de
salariés du privé ce que ça induit
derrière chez le retraité dieuzième
élément sur la question de la
Contre-Réforme de
60 ans à 62 ans en 2010 même Ligas pour
prendre des sources quand même qui qui
élargissent en fait la permet d'élargir
la réflexion un disque indique pardon
que l'annoncement du sas de précarité
explose du fait des conséquences du
report de l'âge légal du droit de départ
à la retraite vous savez on rassure tout
le monde ce qui s'épanouissent dans leur
métier on le souhaite on est là pour ça
ils peuvent y rester il y a aucun
problème nous on demande simplement la
possibilité et le droit de partir
ensemble à 62 et avant la position de la
CGT c'est 60 mais ces deux éléments
amènent quand même à chacune des
contre-réformes ça toujours été les
salariés qui devaient payer finalement
systématiquement et pourquoi on appelle
ça une contre-réformes parce qu'une
réforme est nécessaire peut l'être il y
a celle de 82 qui permet de réaugmenter
les pensions de la population et de ne
plus avoir des de moins avoir de
retraite pauvres notamment par la
possibilité de départ à l'âge de 60 ans
c'est une réforme de justice et de
progrès social pas un recul
supplémentaire je mes propos du être
maladroit aussi parce que je partage
complètement ce qu'a dit la sénatrice
madame jasmin sur la question des femmes
et des retraités de preuves évidemment
je le partage pleinement ce que j'ai
voulu dire très précisément c'est que
u égard ou comparativement aux autres
pays européens nous n'avions pas ou peu
de retraite de misère et que bien sûr il
y a encore trop de retraités pauvre d'où
la question 2200 euros traité mais d'une
manière indécente par celles et ceux qui
ne perçoivent pas puisque cet effet de
communication est le seul présenté comme
une justice sociale comme une mesure de
justice sociale qui aurait dû être
appliquée comme ça a été rappelé depuis
2003 à 85% du SMIC mais pour avoir
participé comme mes collègues au
concertation et pas aux négociations
c'est dire l'état du dialogue social
dans ce pays que des concertations
jamais de négociations
[Musique]
vous avez posé tout à l'heure c'est dire
la gravité du sujet et de la situation
sur la question des carrières longues
nous il y a un élément qui là devrait
être une mesure de justice sociale qui
devrait prendre en compte la totalité
des mesures des citoyens des salariés de
ce pays des procédants des congés
maternité paternité plus et mieux des
années d'études parce que quand on fait
des études c'est bien pour être
performant dans nos entreprises ensuite
et qui participent à l'activité du pays
aux richesses créées dans ce pays quand
on est contraint au chômage pourquoi il
y a la limitation et l'attaque qui a été
faite qui est d'une violence absolue où
là aussi toutes les organisations
syndicales étaient opposées là aussi
nous on considère que les notions de
validation pour le chômage et la Valette
et la maladie pardon devait être prise
en compte pour améliorer les carrières
longues dernière chose sur la question
de la pénibilité
priori pas que nous qui sommes dissipés
les la question des critères la première
élément on l'a fait comme proposition la
notion de contrôle et de contrepartie
aux aides publiques c'est-à-dire quoi
c'est assez simple le budget est loué
nous vous demandons d'imposer de
contrôler de conditionner pour pour que
les corrections soient réalisées c'est
pas du plus en budget c'est une
possibilité et une main que vous avez
sur la pénibilité on a une approche
différente mais complémentaires les
salariés sont différents les
organisations syndicales aussi nous on
considère qu'il faut qu'il y ait un
trimestre validé par année d'exposition
aux critères de pénibilité limité à 5
années voilà mais de quoi nous parlons
des femmes de ménage des travailleurs et
travailleuses en 38 en posté
qui sont confrontés aux produits
chimiques c'est assez élément là que
nous discutons et c'est un élément
important pour avoir enfin la
possibilité d'une
d'une retraite descente pardon sur la
question de capitalisation je vous
rassure tout et tous si ce projet avance
évidemment elle aura lieu elle sera
subie pas choisie puisque les 300 et
quelques milliards d'euros versés chaque
année
aiguise les babines d'une partie de ceux
pour qui c'est un marché et alors que
pour nous c'est un bien commun
évidemment que la conséquence de ça ça
va induire des retraités extrêmement
pauvres voire de misère pour répéter le
propos qui a été dit précédemment et
ensuite des retraites moins défavorables
pour ceux qui pourront se les payer
c'est ça la société française que nous
voulons c'est ça les conséquences d'une
retraite de capitalisation ça serait
parce que tout le monde ne pourra pas se
la payer et on le voit aujourd'hui à
chaque fois que la protection sociale
est attaquée c'est comme ça que ça se
termine
et pour terminer moi je tiens à vous
remercier dommage que ce temps ne soit
pas plus long pour qu'on puisse
approfondir aboutir expliquer vous voyez
les nombres d'incompréhension et de
précision que nous avons les uns et les
autres à apporter pour avancer vous
savez je vais paraphraser une collègue
de la CFTC qui a dit la dernière fois à
l'Assemblée nationale que nous avons été
reçues en fait alors que les
travailleuses et les travailleurs les
salariés font tourner ce pays
qu'est-ce qu'on vous a fait et c'est pas
vous que je m'adresse mais d'abord au
Parlement pour nous infliger ce projet
merci de cette conclusion ensuite
oui oui
rapidement alors sur sur le minimum de
pension pour pour s'en souvenir bien
évidemment le minimum de potion doit
être égal au minima au SMIC puisque
effectivement quand on est le salaire
minimal c'est le SMIC on est à la
retraite on doit on doit pouvoir
bénéficier au moins de ce minima je
rappelle quand même que dans ce pays le
seul de pauvreté il est à 1102 euros
voilà et que beaucoup de retraités
aujourd'hui sont en deçà et j'en profite
pour pour effectivement
rappeler que 18% des Français en grande
pauvreté effectivement réside et bien
dans les outre-mer et que c'est pas
forcément un problème de retraite mais
c'est plutôt un problème de vie chère et
que il faut travailler sur ses
problématiques là il n'y a pas de raison
que les produits qui arrivent et qui
sont vendus dans les outre-mer soit
pratiquement 50% plus cher qu'en
métropole c'est d'abord me semble-t-il
qu'il faut travailler travailler sur la
question du pouvoir d'achat travailler
bien évidemment sur la pérennité des
emplois dans les outre-mer sur sur des
idées alors sur la retraite progressive
je l'ai déjà dit on ne souhaite pas que
ça fasse baisser les pensions des gens
mais il y avait quelque chose qui était
intéressant
d'ailleurs je l'avais proposé au
ministre du travail c'est de remettre en
place par exemple le contrat de
génération le contrat de génération n'a
pas fonctionné parce que les entreprises
n'ont pas voulu qu'il fonctionne et je
leur ai même dit sur le temps de la
plaisanterie même si c'est filmé je vais
le refaire que si le contrat de
génération était trop connoté François
Hollande il suffisait de changer son nom
voilà mais en tout cas on pouvait le
remettre on pouvait on pouvait le
remettre on pouvait le remettre on
pouvait le remettre en place bien
évidemment mon organisation est opposé à
la capitalisation la capitalisation si
elle est subie et quand on regarde là où
il y a des pensions basées sur la
capitalisation un krach boursier ou il
se passe quoi que ce soit économiquement
vous avez une systématique des pensions
il a qu'à regarder ce qui s'est passé
dans les pays nordiques qui étaient
donnés en exemple pendant un moment à
aujourd'hui ils reviennent tous tous ils
reviennent tous sur un autre système de
retraite parce que les pensions dès que
ça va pas elle baisse et que donc c'est
pas possible pour nous le meilleur
système à aujourd'hui c'est encore le
système le régime par répartition adossé
à côté avec la retraite complémentaire
retraite complémentaire gérée par les
interlocuteurs sociaux c'est ça
l'efficacité me semble-t-il voilà et
c'est des choses et non pas mettre un
chapeau de capitalisation qui il est
vrai ne profiterait que plus riche des
des retraités enfin
[Musique]
bon moi j'espère que le taux de chômage
sera 5% un jour c'est pas le cas jusqu'à
présent on est plutôt on est plutôt
autour de 7 et on a bien du mal à
descendre en dessous de 7% et que donc
et que donc le bon chiffre quand on fait
des projections du corps c'est c'est
voilà c'est et que le déficit est créé
parce que on passe de 5 et après le
quinquennat on repasse à 7 donc le
déficit projeté et artificiel voilà il
faut bien le il faut bien l'avoir en
tête et que effectivement avec un taux
de chômage à 5% et bien on aura plus on
aura plus de cotisations mais faut-il
encore que les emplois soient des
emplois pérennes faut pas que ça soit
des emplois précaires à temps partiel
parce qu'il est là le problème et le
problème et c'est bien pour ça et je
reviens à mon propos liminaire
travaillons d'abord sur les conditions
d'emploi sur l'emploi sur les contrats
de travail dans ce pays avant de
regarder de baisser d'un côté de 25%
l'indemnisation au chômage ou de vouloir
faire travailler les Français de plus
merci pour terminer
voilà et pour compléter rapidement je
vais reprendre les éléments de Michel
sur le taux de chômage en particulier
parce que on voit bien que l'approche du
corps est très
synthétique et Macron vu qu'il partent
du PIB d'évolution de la productivité et
du taux de chômage mais taux de chômage
catégoria or la situation de l'emploi ne
peut pas se résumer au taux de chômage
catégoria vu que vous avez les autres
catégories de chômage vous avez le halo
du chômage dont une étude récente de
l'Insee a montré qu'il ne baisse pas
c'est 2 millions de personnes dans notre
pays de Halo du chômage et il n'a pas
baissé depuis 5 ans lui et puis et bien
ce qui compte c'est la masse salariale
après tout et il faut avoir nous on
n'est pas pour augmenter les cotisations
on pense les taux de cotisations parce
que c'est pas nécessaire mais c'est la
masse salariale qui doit augmenter via
un partage de la valeur rééquilibré via
une gouvernance plus responsable des
entreprises et ça va faire le lien
directement avec la capitalisation parce
que là comme on dit il faut travailler
sur l'emploi le travail
avant de parler des retraites et parler
aussi des transitions et des évolutions
que ça va avoir qui vont être
structurelles sur notre vie notre
organisation de l'activité économique et
de la vie de nos concitoyens et bien il
faut d'abord établir une gouvernance
responsable des entreprises avant de
pouvoir parler de capitalisation parce
qu'on pourrait se dire nous on l'avait
évoqué ça pourrait permettre de
reprendre pied dans le capital de nos
grandes entreprises et ça on y est
plutôt favorable mais il faut d'abord
mettre les
l'encadrements au niveau de la
gouvernance des entreprises et au niveau
de la finance pour que tout ça soit géré
de manière responsable parce que
aujourd'hui les retraites par
capitalisation sont un frein à
l'investissement des entreprises vu que
les grandes entreprises préfèrent
distribuer des dividendes faire
augmenter le cours de l'action plutôt
qu'investir je citerai une citation de
Monsieur larryfing patron de BlackRock
qui avait pris l'habitude d'envoyer une
lettre tous les ans au directeur général
des entreprises dont il est actionnaires
y compris en France et qui au mois de
mai a déclaré ben non ce n'est pas aux
entreprises d'investir dans les
transitions
écologique
énergétiques etc donc pareil toujours
pourquoi c'est à l'état de financer oui
donc on continue à privatiser les
profits et à mutualiser les pertes parce
que c'était il était sous la pression de
fond de pension qui sont ces principaux
clients voilà donc la capitalisation
pourquoi pas marginalement parce que
notre système est le mieux établi mais
avec ces conditions-là d'abord je vous
citerai un exemple allez demander à nos
collègues de la tecoère dont on envisage
de délocaliser les emplois alors que
l'origine elle est toute neuve elle
était construite en 2018 et ben c'est un
fond de pension qui est actionnaire
à fond d'investissement dont les fonds
de pension sur actionnaires donc on voit
bien que un système de retraite ne peut
pas tenir si votre système de retraite a
pour objectif de vous faire virer de
votre entreprise parce que il faut
sortir des résultats et d'ailleurs j'en
reviens à un dernier point sur les
comparaisons internationales de même
qu'on a dit que les âges qui étaient
cités ne sont pas comparables parce que
c'est pas les mêmes indicateurs en fait
et bien sur le poids dans le PIB c'est
pareil parce que quand vous êtes un
régime majoritairement en capitalisation
vu qu'on compare les cotisations et ben
le but d'un régime par capitalisation
cette cotiser entre guillemets pas trop
pour que ça soit le rendement des
capitaux qui génère le capital en fin de
carrière pour avoir une retraite donc on
voit bien et tout ça se fait au
détriment des investissements et de dans
la transition
écologique en particulier et j'en viens
sur le taux de natalité parce
qu'effectivement il faut revenir je
pense qu'un objectif de notre pays doit
être de renouveler ses générations pas
d'avoir une démographie croissante mais
au moins de renouveler ces générations
et pour ça faut traiter les causes de
aussi pénalise la natalité aujourd'hui
alors c'est d'abord beaucoup de
précarité chez les jeunes et d'ailleurs
ça me permet de revenir quand vous êtes
travailleur des plateformes alors
d'abord vous cotisez peu pour la
retraite et vous serez rattrapé par la
solidarité plus tard effectivement c'est
une des
anomalies qui se construit dans la vie
active et qui pénalisent notre système
de retraite et ça fera le corriger ok
pourquoi pour qu'on soit indépendant
pour entrer dans l'emploi etc pendant
une période limitée mais pas pour
travailler 5 ans ou 10 ans dans ce
statut qui fait que vous cotisez pas et
vous êtes un incapable de vous
construire un projet de vie et donc bah
oui bah pas de projet familial pas
d'enfant pareil pour l'anxiété
écologique et bien il faut y remédier et
je pense que le gouvernement aurait bien
mieux à faire à travailler sur ces
sujets qui sont vraiment
urgents
sociétalement plutôt que d'un travailler
sur une réforme de retraite
inutile injuste et brutale voilà
juste un point non non parce que je
viens de voir que c'est en train de de
sortir un peu sur Twitter l'ensemble des
organisations participants à
l'intersyndical ce sont adressés au
députés pour recevrez probablement dans
la matinée ce même courrier qui vous
sera adressé à tous individuellement
voilà
en tout cas merci
et la deuxième ouais le courrier était
adressé ce matin mais juste en
transmission entre les deux auditions
l'histoire retiendra peut-être que c'est
pendant le l'audition des organisations
syndicales au Sénat que la pétition
intercelicale a franchi la barre du
million de signataires ce matin donc
c'est un petit symbole
avec mes chers collègues
voilà
bon allez on se calme on se calme nous
avons encore les organisations
patronales en tout cas merci à vous
quatre un de cet échange musclé au
départ mais néanmoins indispensable pour
nous et pour vous je pense merci
beaucoup
vous le voyez même si la réforme des
retraites est actuellement étudiée à
l'Assemblée nationale qui vient de
rejeter l'article 2 sur l'index senior
le Sénat a déjà commencé ses travaux
comme il s'agit d'un texte budgétaire il
faut aller très vite la commission des
affaires sociales a donc déjà entamé une
série d'auditions ça a commencé par
Olivier du soft le ministre du Travail
qui porte la réforme hier la commission
a entendu le président du corps le
Conseil d'orientation des retraites et
vous venez de l'entendre elle a entendu
les organisations syndicales lors d'une
audition commune la CGT Force Ouvrière
la CFDT et la CFE CGC des syndicats qui
sont revenus sur leur échange avec la
première ministre c'était cet automne en
amont de la réforme et ils estiment
qu'ils n'ont pas été assez entendu nous
avons été très déçus ont-ils dit l'un
des points de blocage notamment pour la
CFDT c'est l'allongement de l'âge de
départ en retraite mais lors de cette
audition il y a eu aussi des échanges
assez virulent entre les syndicats et
les sénateurs je vous propose d'écouter
l'intervention de Thomas Vacheron le
représentant de la CGT et dans la foulée
la réponse de la présidence Catherine de
roche la présence de la commission des
Affaires sociales et de la sénatrice
Doisneau qui a tenté d'apaiser les
choses écoutez
nous insistons les citoyens regarderont
attentivement le vote de chaque
parlementaire répondez positivement à
leurs attentes
répondez positivement à leurs attentes
on est là pour échanger et alerter
s'il vous plaît on se calme on se calme
on débat on se calme on n'est pas on
n'est pas dans l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée nationale s'il vous plaît
donc on se calme
on se calme on se calme mais jamais
chacun le verra chacun pourra le voir
mais ce n'est pas c'est une forme de
menace je persiste des signes mais
néanmoins nous continuons le débat je
vous remercie voilà mais tout le monde
sait tout ce que tout le monde vote donc
il y a pas besoin voilà donc c'est bon
voilà Michel bogas
de me couper mon électricité ou de
menacer ma famille ou m'envoyer des
mails et des lettres de menaces au
parlementaire c'est inadmissible voilà
ce n'est pas le sujet mais il y en a qui
qui poursuivent dans cette voie donc je
tiens à dire
la présidence fait référence à certains
responsables syndicaux qui dans la
presse ont expliqué qu'il pourrait en
venir à couper l'électricité dans les
permanences voire même au domicile des
députés ou des sénateurs qui
soutiendraient la réforme je vous
propose d'écouter dans la foule et la
réponse de la sénatrice de haneau qui a
tenté d'apaiser les choses après ces
échanges virulents
je crois que c'est important que vous
compreniez que en tout cas moi je me
sens pas dans une seringue et que je ne
veux pas l'être ni par les uns ni par
les autres
je pense qu'il faut simplement du
respect nos enfants nous regardent nos
petits-enfants nous regarderons je pense
qu'on laisse une mémoire collective
mais cette audition a été aussi
l'occasion pour les syndicats de
dénoncer les injustices de la réforme
selon ils sont revenus sur les problèmes
de pénibilité dans les carrières hachées
la pénibilité qui ne se cumule pas ils
ont aussi évoqué le temps partiel imposé
car pour de nombreux salariés et ils
n'ont pas la main sur ce temps partiel
imposé et cela a des impacts ensuite sur
leur retraite ils ont aussi parlé ces
syndicats de l'index senior qui a été
rejeté à l'Assemblée je vous en ai parlé
mais d'après ces syndicats il faut faire
une vraie loi il faut tout mettre en
oeuvre pour empêcher les licenciements
voilà pour les organisations syndicales
désormais les échanges continuent avec
les organisations patronales je vous
propose d'écouter les représentants du
Medef et de la CPME je vous laisse
suivre les échanges et on se retrouve
tout de suite après
à présent
les représentants des organisations
patronales et j'indique l'u2p m'a fait
savoir qu'elle ne pouvait être
représenté nous entendons donc madame
Diane de peyroix du Medef Monsieur Eric
chevet vice-président en charge des
affaires sociales de la CPAM
j'indique que cette audition fait
l'objet d'une captation vidéo
retransmise en direct sur le site du
Sénat je vais donner la parole à nos
intervenants afin qu'ils exposent
brièvement les principales observations
d'organisation qu'il représente sur ce
texte avant qu'un débat ne s'engage avec
nos rapporteurs et les habitants nous
René Paul Savary et Sylvie vermeiller
qui a présenté la commission des
finances puis avec nos commissaires je
vous laisse la parole qui commence
madame de Perroy
madame la Présidente Mesdames les
rapports tristes et mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs donc comme vous m'y
invitez je vais faire une synthèse sur
notre position
écouter notre notre position sur le
texte que vous allez examiner
prochainement
est une position où nous avons exprimé
un avis globalement positif saluant une
réforme courageuse et équilibrée qui
doit permettre de préserver durablement
l'équilibre du système de retraite par
répartition
nous constatons qu'il n'y a pas de
recette miracle et que si on souhaite
assurer l'avenir de ce modèle social
tout en maintenant le pouvoir d'achat
des actifs et des retraités il s'agit de
travailler plus longtemps
et si nous ne faisons rien et bien nous
allons laisser la situation des se
dégrader ce qui n'est ni souhaitable ni
tenable dans le temps ni soutenable dans
le temps dans un contexte économique
très incertain et puis avec un contexte
de déficit public qui n'ont jamais été
aussi élevées d'ailleurs je me
permettrai
donc en fait par rapport à ce qui peut
être dit et présenté nous pensons que le